The team that is in last place is only five games behind the team that is in first place.
I'm muted by the way.
Instead of three points for win, it's five.
You know what team that is?
That's me!
That is Miles' team.
Which is... if you, for instance, if Miles' team played Brawl Pro's team, who's in first place right now, and 5-0'd them, then they would go from last to first, and Brawl Pro's team would no longer be in first place.
So there's a huge amount of points on the line today to incentivize playing the first day, then learning, then coming back on Friday, playing again, and then getting a cheating for Sunday.
So you'll be playing everybody again today.
All of you did this on Wednesday, so you're all experienced and you know how to do it now.
We've all done this together before.
And then this is your chance to beat up the people who got you on Wednesday and show off the stuff that you've learned and work with your coaches and get some new stuff, some new data.
And it's all worth more points.
So it's going to be...
really important.
Every game is really, really important.
No, I pressed the wrong button!
I took a screenshot!
Five points is a ton of points.
So...
I'm scared.
Good luck out there.
Yay!
No pressure.
Right.
I was about to say...
Yeah, no pressure.
Sorry, we're just sitting on intel.
Almost double.
It's like double jeopardy, basically.
Everything is worth almost double.
My fifth move!
I learned the low-key chat!
That is my fifth move!
I do this!
Boom, boom, boom, boom!
And then I do this!
This is my fifth move!
The fifth move!
And I think for a lot of people tomorrow, if you're in the LA area...
And then I do...
And then I do this!
That is my fifth move!
I'm not listening, by the way.
They're talking about setup stuff.
I'm fucking going.
I'm grinding.
Oh, damn.
Dude, Steve's doing it.
I'm on my way to tribe over there.
Pull up.
Make the trip.
But yeah, otherwise, any questions?
Anything anybody needs to know?
Or are we done with the game?
If I lose any matches, I blame BrawlPro's absence.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm with you.
Let's go moral some hell.
What the hell, bro?
Open trash can.
What have I ever done to you?
Damn.
No, I like that.
That's my teammate right there.
No, no, no.
Yeah, so we talked about prizes.
I talked about it on my stream.
Oh my god, please.
I can't see.
Is this guy on Wi-Fi?
Is it me?
I can't tell.
I can't see.
You can pay to get the EVO.
For flight, hotel, registration.
I mean, you can choose whether or not you want to enter the tournament.
That's up to you.
If you want to play in Tekken or some other games with EVO, you definitely can.
It's okay.
My fifth move is going to come in clutch.
For teams in first and second, they are from junk food.
For teams in third and fourth, they are from custom controllers from FCM and Granola.
And for everybody in the tournament.
We all sent you Chipotle codes today.
I'm sorry if you're in Canada, by the way.
Chipotle!
Chipotle, it's fine.
But we also have something for everybody.
There's a prize.
I'll be showing it off on Sunday.
But we have something that we want to give everybody for participating.
And then everybody for participating is also going to get two gift subs depending on where your team place is.
So it doesn't matter what.
You'll get something physical and something digital.
Oh god.
You can't duck this again because you don't learn.
Nobody learns.
Oh my gosh.
It depends on how your team does today.
It's okay.
My fifth move right here.
Oh shit.
Okay.
My fifth move right... Oh, never mind.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
I'm so sorry.
Are you ready?
Let's game.
Good luck everybody.
Goodbye.
Wait, everybody's leaving but I'm going to win all the games.
Good luck gamers.
I'm going to win all the games.
Oh god.
Okay.
And then...
And then I can do it again.
Without him like yelling in my ear.
Oh my gosh.
Hello everybody.
Sorry, I'm like in the game.
Hey, congrats on Dango-sh or whatever.
Oh my god.
I did it.
I learned a fifth move and it's actually coming in clutch.
What's your new move?
What did we...
The low kick.
I just spam the low kick.
And then I'm...
Spam the low kick into a hop kick.
Oh, that's good.
Wait, do you have the hop kick combo?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I figured it out.
I learned.
Good.
I can't wait to see it.
Now the question is can I use it in like actual like on our players?
You're probably going to get obliterated by ESAM.
Oh, 100%.
That guy hit purple.
Everybody else, I think you're good.
I think you're good.
Why the fuck is he in my elo?
I don't know.
This match should be facing slime or you.
Yeah.
I think they didn't expect him to get good.
So fast because like it's his first time but...
But he comes from fighting games.
Like what?
Yeah, he's a dork.
He's a big dork and he cares a lot which means you should put them high.
You know what I mean?
He should get like a handicap.
Or I should get the handicap.
One more?
Yeah.
Like if you win one round, it's over.
Yeah, exactly.
If I get one round, I win both sets.
That should be the handicap.
You guys talking about Shemesh?
Shemesh man?
Hell yeah.
It's not fair.
Why am I facing that guy?
No, he's... you got it.
What do you mean?
Don't worry about it.
She doesn't.
It's okay.
What the fuck?
No, dude.
He's purple.
Yeah, what the fuck am I gonna do?
Purple means nothing.
Purple means nothing right now.
Purple means nothing?
No, purple's really good actually.
Yeah, what do you mean?
The co- is it Cody purple?
That's where really good players are.
Yeah.
They're really good though.
You're right.
Purple means nothing.
I'm gonna go get my co-.
That means you mean nothing, Cody.
I just think... I think he's gonna mash the hell out of you and there's not gonna...
Like, law is just buttons.
He's just gonna kick you.
But good luck.
Bro, am I even gonna touch him?
No.
My goal is to hit him one time.
You went 2-3.
Oh, wait.
Did I went 2-3?
I did.
Yeah.
Because he couldn't predict me because I didn't know what I was doing.
So, he didn't know what I was doing.
Hold on.
I gotta show my chat something.
One sec.
Oh my god.
Please.
Alissa, please.
Oh my god.
I'm messing up.
I muted myself.
I got scared.
I thought... I pictured her as ESAM.
Even though ESAM doesn't even play Alissa.
I fucking hate Alissa.
I hate... They're too fast!
You're too fucking fast!
Stop!
Fucking stop!
Someone turn it off!
Oh god.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I can't do my special...
It's so true.
Does anyone know how much it is to buy tears in this game?
Like in the battle pass?
No, right?
Do you guys spend money?
So, there's a tulip at level 54 that goes on your head.
And I could make myself a Pikmin.
And I want it real bad.
But not if it's like $300.
You know what I'm saying?
Like...
Wait.
How many tears do you have to buy?
Uh... A lot.
Let me see.
We'll increase battle pass by 20.
That's 2,000 tokens.
If I do that, I'll be at 59.
Also, apparently we're supposed to join the lobby.
Oh, whoops.
Alright, one sec.
Okay.
I just got here to...
Oh shit!
Welcome back!
Howdy, coach!
Yo, what's up?
You just spend your money.
You should do it.
20 bucks for a Pikmin, dude?
Okay, but what about the content?
You could put that on your thumbnail.
Thumbnail?
Yeah!
You could use that as your thumbnail!
I guess so.
For your highlights!
And then the title would be, I spent how much in Tekken 8?
Oh, wait!
No, I need more than that!
No, because I'm at 29.
I need to get to 56.
It would be...
Dude, that's expensive.
It's like 40 bucks.
Holy shit.
You'll earn it back on your YouTube highlights.
You'll earn it back.
Not on this video.
Nobody's clicking on that.
Unfortunately, we went crazy.
Scarra said that he's gonna rip off his shirt if he wins against Beast.
I'm gonna have to throw.
I'm playing against Sean.
I have to activate good timeline.
I'm sorry.
It's just I need to see it happen.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm back.
Wait, why am I playing against fucking Sean?
I don't know.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna...
That's not the match.
Yeah, this is not my match.
We didn't train for that guy.
Yeah, I didn't train for him.
I'm gonna play like Eddy.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Please play King.
Okay.
Get in there.
Let's go.
I have Eddy locked in.
This is stage one, two, three.
I never played this character in my life.
Let's fucking go.
We haven't even started.
This is a...
Isn't it Kaiser's lobby?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
He's doing that thing.
Oh, I see what you mean.
Stage three.
Oh my God.
He's doing the thing I do.
I thought you meant like what two.
Oh my God.
This character is gross.
No, I don't have...
Oh my God.
Is this how people feel?
That's what you do.
That's what I do.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
Oh no, it's five rounds.
Please.
What is happening?
I don't know.
Secret rule set that I wasn't aware of.
Five rounds of Toys R Us.
Oh my God.
Now I know how other people feel when they play against me.
I know.
It's a test round?
I don't understand what's happening.
I don't know.
I guess.
They accidentally made a lobby with five, so they don't think it's a test.
Yeah.
Oh.
I've never seen five dots up there.
How high can it go?
It can't go to seven, right?
That'd be crazy.
That should be the finals.
First to seven.
Yeah.
A lot of adaptation going on there.
Oh my God.
You know what?
Maybe King is bullshit.
Holy shit.
I mean, he's definitely good.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't want people to know how my fifth move.
I went to the bathroom, guys.
I feel like I'm going to barf.
Oh, they're waiting for you to say... oh yeah, he went to the bathroom.
Okay.
Get him!
3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3-3!
I can't!
He's just grabbing me!
True?
Wow.
Oh my god!
This game is truly unfair.
Holy shit, somebody nerf King, please!
You know, we should really ban this character.
Kronix is like, you know what, maybe I just play this guy instead.
He has a shotgun?!
Wait, where did he get the shotgun?!
I think he likes to apple his hammer into shotgun.
It's a cosmetic, you can use it once.
They're legal in the tournament!
Wait, how do I get a shotgun?
Don't.
Do not.
You're not allowed.
She's like, smacking her lips like, hmmm.
You need a license.
Hmmmm.
I'm from Canada, I don't...
The tournament's gonna be over, so...
I don't know how I feel, I'm from Canada.
Hahaha!
Oh, look.
I can't believe it.
He showed me what a true King player can do.
He doesn't even play King, what the fuck?
I can't believe it, guys.
You know, maybe King is bullshit.
Hahaha!
Chat!
Maybe King was...
King is pretty bullshit.
Hahaha!
Right to bear arms, America.
Fuck yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, who are you fighting?
Okay, back.
I am...
I'm fighting Amor, I'm pretty sure, right?
Where...
Oh.
Join the lobby, Amor!
Wait.
Oh, right, right, that's so stupid.
We're making a different one.
Why is this a five round?
Oh, because we're on five rounds.
Yeah, five rounds, so we gotta make a new one.
Freaking Kaiser, man.
What the heck.
Oh my god, you should have been making the lobby, BrawlPro.
Yeah, but he wasn't here.
Wow.
So unprofessional.
I was telling everyone that like, if I lose any, I blame you for lack of team support.
Yeah.
My morale is so low now because you were late.
I'm not gonna lie.
I've been late to pretty much everything my whole life.
I swear, dude.
If I lose, we blame BrawlPro.
Hold on, I'm just learning something about you, Doki.
Someone said your fanbase is called Dragoons?
Yeah!
And it's shortened to Goons?
Yeah, oh.
No.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Who told you that?
There's a double agent here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's nothing wrong with commanding an army of goons.
Someone say it's a little bit respectable depending on how you feel about it.
Are you one of them?
Are you one of them, Matt?
Are you a gooner?
He's on the inside!
He's been gooning.
Alright, I'm losing.
I'm throwing every single one.
Come on!
Oh, wait.
He got caught.
Wait, why are the shirtless?
Why am I supposed to play?
I got so used to the shirt.
The no shirt.
Bought some clothes, just popped into a store.
Yeah, this is not fair.
What is this script?
Oh my god.
I don't like this.
Now that she doesn't have a shirt, I don't like this anymore.
You guys started right away?
Yeah.
Are we?
Okay!
Are we supposed to not start?
No, no, no.
Fuck them up.
Because I don't know anymore.
Up the dokerooty!
Yay!
Slow that shit down.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
I'm a little delayed.
She's doing that thing.
Okay, I've never seen that.
Me too.
I've never seen that either.
I was like, what?
Oh my god.
She's doing...
She's pulling that off of me.
Oh, no way that hopkick.
Bro, she keeps hopkicking.
I was supposed to hopkick.
This is not fair.
This is my first game of the day.
Okay.
Anyway, and now I back up.
Wait, actually, no.
I don't.
Now you go in.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
I got it!
Let's go.
Wait, you won?
Yeah, I won that fight.
Me too.
I honestly thought so too.
I was so surprised.
One more?
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was not ready.
Perfect.
You're insane.
I told you the fifth move is all it takes.
We're getting another game?
Let's go.
It's the fifth move.
Nobody expects it.
It was Unk being like, here's a fifth one.
And she was like, It's like a Zelda game.
It comes out of the chest and it's just your whole game plan now.
Yeah, that's just it.
You're gonna use it in the next boss.
Yeah, you gotta use it everywhere.
Yeah, they've like planned for four moves, but they've never planned for the fifth one.
They never...
It like mixed them up.
The mental stack is too high.
Imagine if I learned a sixth move.
Get your ass out of there.
Yeah.
But you better take off your shirt.
I wanted a turn.
That game was not a fun.
You wanna get in all the king action.
Two jaguars and a bear.
And a robot.
We're gonna Eiffel Tower.
Slime.
The goon accusations really held weight.
Oh my goodness.
It might just be true.
Where the fuck is...
Where is Amore?
Wait, she's gone.
Oh no, she's over there.
Slime, get out.
Slime really wants to play.
He's itching, man.
He heard about the king sandwich.
He's that guy at the rotation that plugs in before anybody asks him to.
GG.
This is tournament, bro.
He takes four puffs.
Is this CTaken?
You ever have somebody go like, is this tournament?
And you're like, yeah.
And they're like, alright.
And they sit down anyway.
What?
GG shake my hand and tell the TL you won.
I mean, I don't mind if he plays for me.
Oh my god, she took all the tricks.
Oh my god, thank you.
I was like...
The sixth secret move.
JK, I had a secret sixth move.
This is like the millennia's naked phase two.
The king scarlet rot.
Oh no.
The fifth move.
There we go.
But she uses this against me.
Don't do that anymore.
That was only on my professional level.
Oh my god.
Wait.
No.
That would have been humongous.
Okay, remove the sixth move.
Stick to the fifth one.
But it's so funny.
You know what?
Maybe keep doing it.
I told you.
You guys didn't believe.
Maybe keep doing it.
Oh my god.
Why did you believe?
My fault.
It's like you put three mom up, but you put in five eggs.
Eggs, eggs, eggs.
Exactly.
But she doesn't.
They don't learn.
That's the thing.
This is a delicious omelet.
Oh my god.
They had the answer and then they stopped having the answer.
And now they remember it again.
Oh no.
They're downloading me.
Oh what the fuck?
King versus king.
What the fuck?
Do it now.
I stepped.
Fight.
Yes.
And then I do the sixth move.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
That cannot be intentional.
There's no way.
I did the square.
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
No, we blocked that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, but then she did this to me.
But she keeps doing stuff.
She can do that?
What?
You know what?
It's fine.
It's all right.
They're both so angry.
I know.
Stop being so angry.
Move number seven.
Oh wait, but she like figured it out.
She's figuring it out though.
What the fuck?
No, I mean...
That's three.
Stop!
Yes.
We did it!
Probably the best Tekken match I've seen in my life.
It worked!
It worked.
Not a block.
You're wrestling!
It works!
What the hell, dude?
They don't learn!
I keep spamming it as long as they don't learn!
That was still sustained.
I don't understand though.
They did learn.
They unlearned.
They unlearned it!
They unlearned it and then stopped learning.
They just- okay, it's because they think I would stop doing it, but I'm so stubborn that I kept doing it.
They were so surprised.
That was crazy.
They're like, she eventually will stop, right?
But I didn't, because I was more stubborn.
Yeah, cinema.
The game is all about cinema.
Well done.
Okay, I have a real question.
If you get hit by five alley kicks and your character is like...
Who the fuck is this guy?
Is that good?
I think that's one of your fans in here.
If an alley kick leads to a true combo...
We need some attention right now.
We're remaking it because it was first to one.
Oh.
Guys are taking two Ls already.
Two bad lobbies?
Wait, so I didn't even need to win that second set?
No, you did.
But...
You did, you did.
Oh.
Oh, the victory conditions.
I would have had to go back to the lobby if you did.
All right.
Nice.
That was so fucking easy.
You got your one dub speed.
I got my one dub.
I don't have to win again.
I already have surpassed Super's record, so I don't need to do anything anymore.
Wait, but for real?
Is the lobby broke for anybody else?
Yeah, it's broken.
I can try to make...
I don't trust your lobbies, bro.
Arata, give us Waffle House.
Dude, I wouldn't order something natural.
We might as well just get Cjam to make the lobby.
Kaiser keeps having to edit his code.
He keeps posting a lobby and then having to edit it.
What?
He can't do it.
That he didn't mean.
How do you edit a link?
Like in the Discord, he keeps like posting the link and then screwing it up.
He's like, oh, my bad.
Did he post the right one?
Yeah.
I don't know.
We have a password now with the wait.
All right.
And we can show the password to everybody, because it's like, yeah, it doesn't matter.
We learned that today.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to go to the bathroom while everybody files in.
Let's go.
What did they talk about in the orientation when I was like running late?
They were like, wow, BrawPro is late.
They actually did call you out.
Wait, what?
I know that.
And I stood up for you and said Sejem has a hair system.
Which he does.
Woah!
I didn't pay attention, I was fucking playing rank.
It's like an FGC like, inside thing that no one talks about.
But I'm breaking this news live today.
Alright.
He has a hair system.
And he's bald in real life.
Nice.
I know.
It's not nice, no.
I mean not nice.
Embarrassing.
Oh my god.
We already got points.
Look at me go.
We're already running it up.
We're already a positive record.
Alright guys, don't fuck it up now.
I worked very hard for that lead.
Those five alley kicks, I worked very hard for.
Okay, rage art done.
Points, points, points.
Alright, if I get on that goddamn wall stage again, I'm random-ing off.
That's crazy dude.
Do you think, do you think like, you could get away with five alley kicks on turn two?
No!
I might do it!
I might do it, but I don't think I'm gonna get away with it.
Try.
Do it.
Try for the one time.
Five alley kicks and the hop kick.
I believe.
Playing like he's fucking Hwoarang.
I was gonna say, that wall is so good.
Like if the back is to the- Okay, thank god, we're on arena.
Okay.
Fine with me.
Which stage don't you like?
Uh, the dojo.
Oh, cause the wall?
Who's that?
Josie.
Round one.
Oh, I love the costume.
Fight.
Yeah.
That's like beach.
Oh my god.
Beach time, Reyna.
Ho ho!
Oh, nice grab!
They're both meeting in Hawaii.
On the beach.
Oh my god.
She's into that jaguar dick.
Wait, what?
For real?
What?
Giga agree.
What a little parrot.
It's okay.
What?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Wow, that anything.
Oh, nice.
You're beautiful, handsome, beautiful.
Beautiful.
Beautiful a third time.
I see a wall.
Take you to the wall.
Allocake to the wall!
We go to the wall?
I see a wall.
What's wrong, bro?
Nice!
Oh, the Allocake!
Okay, so, he's sidestepping every time to stop the first thing.
Oh, pay attention.
You weren't paying attention coach?
I've- Okay.
I'm just going to do this for him.
Sorry, there's a lot of people in the chat.
Oh wow, chat over team, I understand.
I see, I see.
Yeah.
Alright, fine.
I don't know when to get out there, or how to get out in the next spot.
Don't pull dick jabs in your diet.
Yeah.
We'll be good.
Yeah, that's always gonna be a mid.
That's always gonna be a mid when he crashes.
Every fucking time, and I'm trying to just grab to track it, but...
Oh, this guy is buying up.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh nice, nice, you got out!
Does he know how to get up?
He's ducking.
He does not.
Nice.
Yeah, he's ducking.
We're gonna teach you that dope deep.
That's a free follow-up.
Guaranteed damage.
Oh, nice.
My seventh move.
He's gonna sidestep.
Yeah, your seventh move is a guaranteed move.
Fight.
What a hot cake.
I mean, you just read people like that.
It's just as simple as that.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
I mean, talk about improvement.
What?
No.
That's funny as hell.
Lab the matchup.
Reapply.
Boom.
Dead.
That easy.
I'm gonna be just like that tomorrow.
Yeah, me too.
He's just blocking mids.
He beat me yesterday just by midding.
If I just, like, beat that.
He might just start with sidestep again, just autopilot.
I'm gonna see.
He does.
He like his 4-4-2 into the high.
You can duck him.
He's like, oh, I'm gonna go for the second hit of the...
Damn.
Oh my god.
Oh, nice.
The shoulder.
Oh, we ran the drill.
We ran the shoulder drill.
Thinker back to that wall.
Oh my god.
No.
That's all you need.
Beautiful person I've ever met in my life.
Oh my god.
That was perfect.
That's good.
You can't have too many.
But sometimes it's a treat.
He's so good.
Point dispenser.
You're in his mind.
Nice.
That's all right.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're setting up for grab a long time.
Just waiting for you to stand.
Oh.
Nice.
No.
Okay.
Whatever.
Wait.
Wall?
Never mind.
He might block alley kick here.
No.
Oh, nice.
The alley kick.
Hey, hey.
Don't listen to me, man.
I'm just kidding.
I didn't listen to...
I got my five alley kicks.
I don't know how.
He was blocking it.
Oh my god.
The shoulder.
And you just set up another knee.
Look at that.
That one is so broken.
I'm running the fuck over.
Okay.
They're not going to get hit by this in two days.
That's too obvious.
Oh my god.
Knee, shoulder guarantee me again.
I blocked it.
The game is over.
This should have happened two days ago.
Wrap it up.
The game is...
This should have happened two days ago.
So these points add on to the points from two days ago.
So this is making the gap wider between our team and this team.
They're the second?
They're worth five points instead of three.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
All right.
Which team's the second team?
Well, Tony's and MYK's teams, I think they were tied for a second.
Oh.
So it was very close.
Nice.
Yeah, it's Tony's and MYK's team that are the scariest.
Who is this guy?
The Dragoon671.
Is this not private?
What the fuck?
How did this person get in here again?
He was in the last one too.
Yeah.
How did this person get in?
Can we not ban him or kick him?
I think it's Kaiser.
All right.
There you go.
You kick.
There we go.
Oh, there you go.
How the fuck does he keep getting in?
I don't know how he's getting in.
Yeah.
He probably works for Namco or something.
The eternal gooner.
Oh, I gotta get out.
Okay.
Bro, he's hacking the system.
All right.
Slime, remember that he does a little two-hit dance thing.
He likes to go low after that.
So while sending four, if you block it.
Okay.
All right.
And we finished our combos and...
I mean, didn't you beat him?
Didn't you?
I beat him last time, but it was...
It was close.
It was clown world.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was.
It was.
I remember it.
And yeah, he falls for the bear electric a lot when you just keep repeating it.
So I don't know if he still will.
So ready.
Okay.
Got this, man.
Get ready for the next battle.
Let's go.
I almost wore that same thing today.
What he's wearing now.
That should look like a pop tart.
Oh my God.
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, I'm definitely behind you guys.
Okay.
Nice.
He'll be afraid of that for sure.
Round two.
Fight.
Talk.
Yeah.
I didn't mean to do that.
You're going to be the boss.
That's not what I meant.
He's a good player.
You got it.
I got it.
Nice.
You got it.
Oh, that's good.
Nice.
Damn it.
You had a run.
You had to keep that in mind.
Okay.
Oops.
Round three.
Fight.
Alright, I gotta borrow that panic here.
Big.
Oh!
Oh, nice!
Beautiful combo, really.
He's stuck!
Oh!
Let him out!
Come on, man!
Let him out, dude!
He's just in the fucking corner!
Put him in the corner!
Don't let him breathe!
Nice!
What the fuck is this gameplay?
I've never seen that large move.
He called upon Zeus.
It's like a mini-jack.
Nice!
Punish!
That's what I'm talking about, Fly!
Good shit!
Fuck yeah, the shit we talked about!
One more round, brother.
Oh my god, I'm so bad.
I'm so behind.
We should start with a little hop.
Oh my goodness.
We're getting real cute now.
That's all good.
Oh, wow!
That's fucking crazy!
Oh, what?
No way!
Dude!
That's unreal, dude.
Wait, did you guys... did he win?
Mental shatter.
He won!
Oh my god, I'm still watching him beat him up!
That's just a reverse three-up.
Bro, like a model in this opulent mansion.
Oh, man.
Good shit, man.
Wow.
Good reverse.
Fight!
Nice.
Oh.
That's cool.
Alright, you're still ahead.
He whips.
Shit, that's good shit.
I top-kick.
I tried.
Oh, nice.
What the fuck is that?
Is that unblockable?
Yeah, that's an unblockable.
You can twin-paste on him before he gets to you.
Watch your way, Gart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, nice!
He missed!
He has!
Very nice.
Oh, okay.
Oh, he's lovely.
By his large dress, like Mr. Beast chocolate.
He's pretty tall.
He is.
Beast knife.
Beastables.
Bro, look at Mighty Beastable right now, bro.
Oh my god.
Mr. Beast sponsored us.
Okay, I don't know.
He was just doing...
He did neutral air.
I don't know what that is.
Yeah, right.
It's Samus Nair.
I keep left here.
Easy.
Beautiful.
Nice.
It's a combo, but it's okay.
Drop your American reset.
That's what we call that slime.
American reset.
An actual American reset.
You guys low here?
He knew.
You have heat?
It predicted.
He knew.
Oh, nice.
Nice flip.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That's slime.
One more, brother.
This guy learned how to mix and hunting bear stance.
It's over.
That's...
Oh, that would have been a twin piston right there.
We dropped?
Pathetic.
It's a pathetic turn.
Yeah.
He plays pathetically.
I Jesus.
Big agree, slime.
Stop using heat, you pussy.
Bug it.
Nice.
He's a talker.
Okay.
I'm going to go.
You got this cool side wall last time too.
I think it was against him.
That's an actual...
He fell into the bear enclosure.
It just got pushed.
And they were like...
His family was like, oh, someone please.
Bro, he couldn't get out.
He loved Mr. Beast.
Oh my god.
That was so stressful.
Good shit, dude.
When he won rounds, he fucking won rounds too.
It was really scary.
Yeah.
Lars is just kind of steamrolly.
He'll do that.
He just runs you over.
Good shit.
I didn't use back...
Yeah, you downloaded him.
Dude, slime.
Everything we talked about, bro.
You are doing that shit with purpose.
I applied it.
I know.
It makes me so happy.
I'm going to keep it 100 dot.
I know we're having fun, but you're a really fucking good coach.
I'm serious.
Yeah.
Even beyond the meme shit.
Seriously.
I'm blazing.
The shit you sent me last night was sick.
Thank you.
Yeah, you managed to teach me a fifth move.
That's fucking insane.
I'm going to go.
Yeah, we're cooking.
Oh, yeah, dude.
Get his ass, Matt.
Let's get it.
Jack Jesus.
Real shit.
No.
Yakushima is a breath of fresh air for Shifter right now.
I did not want that.
Oh, this is Shifter rage quit last time.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the wrong map for him.
In the mansion.
I think he's learning now.
How do you even do jack practice?
You got to call up Anakin.
Yeah.
I'm going to go.
Red Bull Anakin.
Red Bull Anakin for $100 an hour.
This is fucking crazy, dude.
Oh, my God.
Matisse, stop.
Don't make him a plank in the beginning of the round.
Oh, no.
Bro doesn't know where he's shooting.
Yeah.
Is there a duck here?
Fight.
Oh, he's tilted.
You can tell.
Yeah.
I think so.
I would be pissed if I had to play again.
I'm going to go.
I'd be furious, dude.
Madman's jackade.
Yeah.
Like, he already won the trip to evil.
Why is he here again?
That's what I'm saying, man.
What the fuck is his problem, man?
Holy shit.
Round three.
Fight.
Oh.
What is that whiff, monkey the animal?
Range five whiff.
I don't think he's thinking anymore.
Not going to lie.
That's too much.
That's too much damage, dude.
No, fuck.
He's a big boy.
I'm done.
I'm rooting for shifter now.
Holy shit.
Just to balance things out.
Okay.
He gets a round.
I got auto-balanced to the other team.
Oh, wait.
Is he going to take a round off?
He took a round off you.
Round four.
Fight.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
We are blocking.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
That is insane.
Bro, all he can do is block.
He's a force.
Drop the stab.
That's a double B.
Don't even need it.
Don't even...
Oh, my God.
It ended fast.
It doesn't fucking end, man.
Doki, how are you delayed if you're in the lobby with us?
I don't know.
That's so weird.
Yeah, you're getting spoilered.
Yeah.
I was screaming.
You're going to have to restart tech.
I think so.
Yeah.
You guys were like, end the stab.
She's still playing.
She's doing strings.
Oh, her PC is potato.
Matt, you know that two hits... the string he did before he did a low heat smash?
The second hit is a high.
Oh.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh -oh.
Big mistake.
That's in the commandments.
Every time.
Time to be punished.
Half bar.
Oh, my God.
Don't let her get up.
What a gamma howl.
What the fuck is this?
Actually, it's my turn.
It's his turn forever.
My turn.
Launch.
You can launch it.
I know.
Dude.
I'm sinking back.
Why does he have a look that's just like, nope, reverse.
I'm going to...
Of course!
Ah, I like the idea.
Oh.
Classic Zettel.
They were killing slime with that.
Did he know?
He doesn't know!
No way.
Bounce?
It's a guard break!
You can't block it!
You've gotta be fucking joking!
I... dude.
Okay.
It'll be a miracle if Shifter makes it to Sunday.
I would destroy my PC.
This is insane.
What if, like, we get the buy?
Where is his bar?!
Bro, we looked away for five seconds and the Skelp is gone!
Two seconds.
Oh my god, two seconds?!
This is fucking unfair.
This character is insane.
Lud, where are you?
Easy.
Oh my god, dude.
I think we ruined his day.
He has like four more rounds to go.
Yeah, that's a joke.
Yeah, that's a hard jam.
How will he face the other four opponents?
Uhhh...
You know what, BrawlPro?
That's a 4-0 sweep.
So you win.
Yeah, yeah, keep it going.
Yeah, but surely you'll win.
You're king players.
You wouldn't let us down, right, coach?
I'm laughing for all you guys yesterday.
I don't have time.
I'm not gonna let you down, right, coach?
I laughed for four people in one day.
When am I gonna laugh for myself?
Four people that you laughed for me?
Okay, but we played though.
You sent me on my way.
You said...
I literally DM'd you.
I said, hey, I'm having trouble with this.
You're like, go check the VOD.
And then you left me alone.
Oh, come out!
I was with slime when you sent that.
Four people my ass, bro.
Okay, three people.
You literally sent me on my way.
You're like, nah, Matt's good.
Here's $20.
Order a pizza.
You're old enough to take care of yourself.
That's what I'm saying.
That's how he treats my ass.
Hot dogs in the sink.
This fucking guy, man.
He just thinks I can do it all.
Matt, you called me broke yesterday.
It's just payback.
Oh my goodness.
Now the chat spam is broke pro.
Like, what is that?
Okay.
Ooh.
I love that move.
Oh.
Boom.
Nice.
Do the alley kicks.
That's guaranteed.
Yes.
Yeah!
Round two.
Oh, okay.
I see.
Fight.
Damn, wah.
It's not a good look if you're the only one that doesn't win a round, bro.
Not a good look.
High as a hot...
The coach doesn't win for us?
After all the points we got for him?
He's late and he loses?
And he loses?
Wait.
Wait, unless...
Ooh.
That's not what I'm talking about.
Oh.
That guy just knows.
Looking like slime out there.
I feel like the more we roast him, the better he does, guys.
No.
I don't think that.
He needs to prove us wrong.
The nothing?
Damn, he's agile.
Dude, the higher level Tekken gets, the more people just run up and do nothing.
It's so scary.
You're just like, what is he gonna do?
Pop, pop.
And it's game.
Alright, alright, alright.
My fault, coach.
I'm so bad at the game.
It's okay.
Rage art?
We win.
Let's go!
Don't worry, I'm gonna see the rage art soon.
I'm gonna armor this black ass Mixle.
Guys, don't worry.
He's rage arting.
He's rage arting now.
Final flight, baby.
Guys, he was definitely starting to feel himself.
He was like, ooh, watch this straight.
And then you just wait, wait.
That's nice.
Nice job.
I got him so behind.
Good shit.
One more, bro.
It's okay.
I'll do my best, boys.
I saw the rage art just then, guys.
Round one.
Nice.
Fight.
Boom.
Good shit.
The coach doesn't know.
This is it.
Uh-oh.
No!
What a fucking giant swing, bro.
What?
Oh my god.
Yes!
He teabagged.
That's our coach.
That's the values he teaches us.
He teabagged from my coach.
He told me to do it after every game.
Please stop.
Slime, you've seen Billy Madison, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're the O'Doyles.
That's this team.
We're just the fucking O'Doyles.
This doesn't bode well if we get to the very end of the movie.
Let's avoid buses.
Wait, what happens at the end of the movie?
What happens?
Don't worry about it.
Is it a good thing?
O'Doyle rules.
Oh my god, alpha air.
Whoa, coach.
Okay, no problem.
Oh, you got cocky there.
Anti-air anime fighter.
Okay, tango.
What the fuck?
You just kicked her.
Yeah, it's a low grab.
You gotta hold down back to attack it.
Oh my god.
No problem, no problem here.
I just wanted to make it close for content.
That's it.
Nice.
Oh, good.
Boom, boom, bop.
Nice.
Alley kick.
Imagine.
Ooh.
Oh.
Nice.
Guess we're game.
Oh, what?
How come we weren't taught that move?
It's too dangerous.
We would kill ourselves doing it.
Break our neck.
His final technique.
Only when you're a god you can do this.
Damn it.
That was a good grab.
Oh.
Okay, I see.
I see, I see.
One more set.
Come on, coach.
You got this.
O'Doyle is being the matrix.
Bless what?
Downloading.
Perfecto para ti.
Let's go.
One.
Fight.
One day we'll all be a hundred Daniels.
Where did that come from?
I'm only 30 Daniels.
Naughty, I think I'm 20 Daniels.
How do you get a hundred Daniels?
They just give you 70 Daniels after you get...
Oh, you get to 30 and they just...
Yeah.
There's just too many Daniels in the world.
You gotta adopt them.
Adopt, don't shop.
Oh, get up.
Get up, coach.
Come on, coach.
Get up, they're beating your ass.
Adrian.
Come on.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, dude.
Oh, yes, sir.
Oh.
Nice.
She's screaming the whole time.
Stop.
I hate this.
Oh, no.
Oh, nice.
She took you to the wall.
Damn it.
No problem.
It's okay.
You bring it back.
Smash a beer bottle.
What a good block.
The punish.
Kaiser might be gaming.
Ooh.
You know, we're just giving them false sense of scaredy.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, we love holding back here.
Yes.
Yeah.
We don't hit any buttons.
No.
No buttons.
Fight.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Nice dick punch.
I didn't know what the second hit was.
Oh.
Yeah.
That might be it.
Oh, yeah.
Damn.
GG.
Oh, GG.
Nice try.
It's okay.
We just wanted to give them one extra point.
You know, we felt bad.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
You gave us all a shard of yourself, BrawlPro.
Yeah.
Across the team because it's just mathematically better, you know?
We add all of us together as one BrawlPro.
I'm okay getting carried by my team.
I'm okay with that.
Bro, it's like the Ninja Turtles getting care- like Splinter, like taking care of those babies and now he's the old Splinter.
And we're the Ninja Turtles.
I'm Raphael though.
I won't be Raphael.
That's fine.
I just- Leonardo, I'll call it.
You guys can have the other two.
Sorry.
Sorry that there's- Doki, do you know the Ninja Turtles?
Yeah!
I'm Donatello!
Okay, there we go.
That means that's the party, dude!
I don't give a shit.
Does it work out any better than that?
Does it work out any better?
It's perfect.
Perfect.
I actually liked Donatello when I was a kid because I thought he was the smartest.
And I thought that was important.
Yeah, that's why I'm Donatello.
But not now?
No, now I just- I want to be like the Chad Leonardo with swords.
Well, sure.
Wait, then Matt- Yeah, then Matt is Mikey.
Michelangelo.
That just makes sense.
That makes sense!
Literally, I couldn't ask for a better turtle.
Because I know- I know he can never be Donatello.
Alright, we got a stack before the next round, so if you guys want to run A- Oh, nice.
We can chill.
Yeah, I got to do a quick match.
I'm feeling kind of- Yeah, I'm going to restart my tech in because I'm 80 fucking seconds behind.
because I'm 80 fucking seconds behind.
You just hooked up your new computer and now you're still on Potato Island.
Hey, look.
In the finals.
Look, it's because- it's like those training weights.
So when the weights are finally off for the finals, I'm unstoppable.
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
That's how it goes.
It's like not 20 FPS, you're like, Oh my god, you see the matrix.
I see an 800 frames.
That'll be good.
Who's next?
I don't know.
Who do we play?
We play...
against...
Let's look at our team brawl pro chat.
Broke's Godot!
Or Godot!
That's awesome!
Godot?
I'm fighting an ace attorney.
Dragunov.
He has like the mask and everything.
We're fighting Tone next.
Alright.
That's BoxBox.
He can beat me 100%.
I played him a lot last night.
Yeah?
How does he feel?
He's getting better.
For sure.
Guys, I swear.
For the finals, the PC will be plugged in.
I swear.
For real this time.
For real chat!
I would never lie to you!
Are you watching the mainstream?
I'm just on a...
Quick matching.
I feel rest.
I swear!
It's gonna be there!
But I'm gonna have it set up before the finals.
So by the time the finals roll up, I'm gonna be a god.
That king.
That doesn't mean she'll use it.
It's unboxed!
The first step is over.
I completed the first step!
Is that what matters?
Yeah.
I completed the first step!
This guy's pretty good, but his offense is kinda weak.
Don't worry.
The frames will be back soon, guys.
It'll be back soon!
Don't worry!
I'm loading in...
See, there you go!
I was loading in the shaders!
I was loading in...
I'm loading in more shaders!
He ducked that one time, but not other times.
I don't expect people to mix up.
The shaders are loading up, guys!
There we go!
It's fine now, see?
Now it's fine!
Now you can see everything!
There!
It's fine.
If he just waits and then does that...
See, look!
It's smooth!
It's so smooth, chat!
But this is my favorite move now.
This is honestly...
I haven't done that yet.
I think it hits wall here?
This cat let go.
This is my favorite move, chat.
And then this.
And then I can do the hop kick.
The perfect move!
It's how I got to this elo.
The best move ever.
Nobody can fucking counter it for some reason.
I don't know why.
Wait, this guy has...
This guy is on wifi.
Look, this guy's wifi.
He deserves to have the frames.
He deserves the treatment.
I'm putting him through with my APC.
No, please.
I'm sorry.
I did not mean that.
Please, I'm so sorry.
I was joking.
I did not mean that.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Goodbye, he broke my arm.
No, see the frames are okay now!
It's okay!
See, look!
Everything is fine!
You guys can see everything!
It just takes a bit to load it in.
Okay, watch this.
And then...
Oh, wait!
What the fuck!
Sir, sir!
You were supposed to let me do a hop kick.
That wasn't what the alley kicks are for.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Guys, it's not looking so good.
JK!
He cheated!
He cheated in front of a king player?
What the fuck is wrong with him?
What is wrong with this man?
How dare you!
Here we go.
He's not gonna duck again.
He never learned.
They never learn when they play against a king.
Oh!
It's fine.
Oh, wait!
He overheard me!
Not!
Oh, he's not gonna duck again.
It's fine.
This time, it's fine.
No!
It's not fine!
I'm so sorry!
Let me go!
No way.
And then my secret hidden six move that nobody knows yet.
Until the finals.
Then people are gonna know in the finals.
That's fucking right.
No more over... Oh shit!
Oh!
Okay.
I'm not gonna lie.
Please, please, please.
Give me that.
Please.
Oh!
Give me that one hit.
Oh.
Oh, that's scary.
It's fine.
And then...
And then it's my turn, right?
Is it my turn?
It is.
Yay!
You bitch.
You whore.
Okay, it's fine.
There we go.
And again!
Oh!
He's fine!
Nobody loves you!
Not even your mom!
Okay.
I'm so sorry.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Get closer, please.
No!
The sides.
There we go.
See?
We did it.
Yay!
How did I hit?
Because I called him loveless.
I called him a loveless child.
And that's how it hits.
I've become a fighting game... gamer.
Get ready for the next one!
That's how it works.
If you tell your enemy nobody loves him, they'll get hurt emotionally and then you win.
The one button rage arts are the win.
Get one and done.
Exactly.
He's not special.
He's not the only one and done.
It's okay, guys.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm loading in the shaders.
It'll be fine.
See?
I told you.
It's fine.
I had to load in the shaders there.
Yay!
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
I don't know how that hit too, but...
I'll take it!
Wait.
I never expect people to counter that.
We try to say the higher you load, the more easily I can counter.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
No!
Please!
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
JK, I'm not sorry.
Oh, he ducked!
JK, I'm still not sorry.
I don't learn.
That's fucking...
Right!
Yeah!
Okay, is he gonna hit?
No, he's not.
It's fine.
He fucking ducked that?
How?
Bro!
He just walks away!
You don't walk away from me!
Oh my god.
How do you just walk away?
How do you lose?
Just turn around and walk away.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He keeps walking away from me!
I don't know what to do!
Surprised Pikachu face.
He just...
He just walks!
It's insane!
I don't know how he does it.
The spacing.
Just turn around.
You know?
Just fucking turn around.
Don't duck!
Oh, thank god.
Don't duck as well.
Oh, nice.
Nice!
No!
I fucked it up, but it's for perfect.
I fucked it up, but it doesn't matter.
Goodbye!
Yay!
We won that...
The reason why we're not in the game yet, in the next round yet, is that we won the game so fucking fast, that like, uh...
We won our set so fast, that we're just chilling now.
We're just practicing warming up.
Nothing works, AlleyKick!
Exactly!
Oh.
We're just waiting.
How are you so good?
Cause I don't need to learn like 20 plus moves.
I just learn like 4 to 6, and then just perfect it.
But you can't predict it, because like, I also throw in random button mashing, so they can never predict it.
Cause it's like, which one is like...
They don't know when like, it's the real match, you know?
If I throw in random button mashing, they can't predict the moves.
Oh my god, bro.
Okay.
Oh my god, she stopped it!
She actually... She's gonna block this, isn't she?
Goodbye.
Look, she's red rank.
She knows how to do it.
When I learn a 7th move, I can beat her.
That's all I'm saying.
The moment I learn a 7th move, I can beat her.
Oh my god, she fucking sucks!
Oh my god!
Just saying, the 5th and 6th move got me to this elo.
Not gonna lie.
The 5th and 6th move got me here.
Jesus!
Holy fuck!
Gotta start throwing out movement.
Hahaha!
Yay!
Boop, boop!
Goodbye!
Yay!
That was so close.
Is she gonna...
Yeah, oh, she is.
Oh, I thought she was gonna duck.
That's not fair.
She didn't.
Why didn't you duck?
Why!
Oh, now you duck?
Okay, I didn't mean now.
Don't start ducking!
I didn't mean now!
Can't believe it.
Oh my god!
Now she does that?!
Bro!
Uh...
Hahaha!
Why don't you duck when I don't want you to duck?!
Bitch!
There you go.
Fuck off!
Um...
What the heck is a passcode?
Oh no, we're starting.
Oh no.
Please.
Please, I'm getting juggled so hard right now.
Please get close to me.
Oh, no.
That's right.
Hahaha!
Give me a sec!
Ah!
Leave your elo!
I'm gonna learn my seventh move and you're going down!
The reds are going down!
When I learn my seventh move.
That's right, Doki's coming!
Hahaha!
The red rings!
You're going down!
Hahaha!
Yay!
Yippee!
Alright, apparently, it matches.
Hahaha!
I'm like, am I one game off of red elo?
Yo, team, you guys have to join the lobby.
No!
Alright, alright.
I just beat a red ranker.
Alright, alright, alright.
Bro, I got a seven win streak.
I'm so cli- Oh my god!
Wait, I get promo?
Are you fucking joking?
I'm nine points off promo.
Hahaha!
I think I'm gonna restart my computer after this.
Make them wait for us so you can get your rank.
Hahaha!
I'm literally nine points off promo.
That's insane.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
The ears don't go up.
Oh, sorry.
Oh...
ESAM does a lot of slide for mid-range.
I'm here.
You remember that?
Totally.
Hahaha!
Guys, it doesn't matter if I show the password.
All my other teammates show their password already.
So, like, I hide it, it doesn't matter.
My teammates are showing the password.
So, it doesn't matter.
Hahaha!
The code is right here.
Thank you.
I'm here.
I'm ready.
Okay, so what does ESAM do again?
Remember when you played him last time?
He did the slide a lot.
He did the slide where it was low from mid-screen.
So, do I just block low?
Hahaha!
I'm so confused.
I don't remember.
Hahaha!
I'm so scared.
So, what do I do?
Coach, what do I do?
Wait, our coach left.
Well...
What?
Bro left and joined SageM!
He didn't even tell me what to do!
Well, Jason, yeah, that's pretty usual, I see.
Hahaha!
He didn't even tell me what to do!
I can't believe it.
I guess I'll never know what to do.
Hahaha!
Our coach went out to get milk, guys.
Yeah, he'll come back.
He'll come back, right?
He'll come back to coach us, right guys?
ESAM's not gonna know my low kick.
He won't expect it.
We're just waiting.
I think we're just waiting for them...
for casters to be ready.
at the moment chat.
So we're just waiting for now.
We're just waiting for now.
Alright, I'm back team.
Sorry they yoinked me for an interview.
So what do I do?
Hahaha!
Oh man...
Um...
You gotta...
Okay, so if he's mid-range, he's gonna maybe do the slide.
The punish on the slide might be...
annoying to just...
explain here.
Because you have to like...
crouch cancel and then do the down-forward...
What?
Hahaha!
Wait, crouch cancel?
What?
Okay, you have...
If you block the slide, just alley kick him...
three times.
Okay.
I got it.
Just alley kick him three times.
I know how to do that.
And after the third alley kick, hit the right punch.
It's a fourth hit.
So that will also...
Okay.
The right punch.
Or you can also just while standing four.
If you block low, then just hit four to do the while standing four.
Oh no.
He's doing the thing.
Who's watching this?
Who can spectate?
Oh my god!
Sam, please!
The worst part is like I hate fighting this guy in rank as well too!
Oh my god!
You know he's...
He's purple!
He can duck!
Hahaha!
Okay, you gotta hit him with the elbow.
When you're sprinting.
Okay.
Yeah, he knows how to duck.
So I have to...
You think he'll duck this?
Yes.
Oh my god!
Goodbye.
Cruel world.
The law is loud!
Oh my god!
This ass is just screaming!
That's why I'm watching this shit muted, dude.
The law is annoying!
I hate playing against law in general.
Even in rank.
Damn.
It's so annoying.
Oh my god!
He just ducks everything!
It's like he's been playing against King players his entire life!
Hahaha!
Hey guys.
It was great existing.
Hahaha!
I existed!
You know...
It went the way I expected it to go.
I'm muting on your effect.
Oh, sorry.
Hahaha!
That's alright.
He's a nerd.
He is!
He's a fucking nerd!
We already talked about this.
He wants the trip so bad.
Oh my god!
How does he...
Hahaha!
This character does a lot of stuff.
Oh!
Yes!
That's fucking right!
He didn't change for my alley kicks!
That's freaking good!
Hahaha!
I got that.
It's fine.
That's a mighty ruler.
This guy is purple.
This guy is purple?
He lets me alley kick him 20 times?
Like, come on!
Bro!
Come on!
Oh no!
That's not it, guys!
Guys, you jinxed it!
Hahaha!
Nice try.
You were alive for a while.
I was.
It was actually crazy.
I've not been alive for that long.
You almost cooked him.
The worst part is like...
I keep being on the right side.
Hey!
We're live!
Don't give him the...
Don't give him the J.
Oh shit!
JK!
I can pull it on both sides!
I'm ambidextrous!
I'm not though.
What does he do?
I don't know.
Do you know?
I'm clicking buttons.
Hell yeah.
Let's go.
He blocked that.
He told me he wouldn't.
Well, if he blocks it, then you grab him after.
He told me he doesn't block those!
Hey!
Hold up.
It's okay.
I got that one round.
Remember, I got one round off of purple.
That should be worth some points.
Yeah, that should be worth some points.
He's literally smurfing at this point.
Hey guys.
I did not exist there.
One point.
My handicap.
That's fine.
He's cheating.
Yeah, honestly.
The slide seems not fair.
I think a nerf is in order.
I think so too.
I got Harada on the line.
I got him on hold because I'm busy.
So if I can't spectate, do I have to restart the lobby or the game?
That's so annoying.
Wait, are you the one who made that lobby?
No, I think it was Tony.
So you can't even join?
Uh...
I'll just watch on Sajan.
I'll just stream.
No giving either of you.
You're delayed.
You're delayed to shit.
I'm not anymore.
I restarted my Tekken.
I swear.
You still can't spectate?
Let's see here.
I cannot.
Mine's up.
Yup.
Almost.
Hell yeah.
Oh!
Oh my god, you bit his dick!
Ah, that sucks.
Remember, Tony, you can challenge that.
The down two.
Is blue higher than purple?
Yeah, blue is higher.
Not by much.
Oh my goodness, we labbed.
Let's go with the duck!
Oh!
Guaranteed a three?
Three is good.
Yeah.
Oh, huge.
Forgot it.
Alley kick!
Dude, I'm holding back.
I feel like I'm holding back there.
You got it.
Island Coney, someone said.
You got this.
Oh my god, a grab.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Yes!
Nice tech.
Nice!
I don't think that hits.
Oh, you're so good.
Oh, what?
Yeah, I didn't think that would land.
Oh my god.
That's funny that that landed.
That's the end of the Rage Art.
Come on, sweetheart.
He fucking techs.
Wow.
Get him.
Rage Art after back one two.
Okay.
All right, cool, cool.
Nice.
Yeah!
Fight.
Oh, you're such a GOAT.
You know what the fuck to do.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Can you press?
What a fucking mugger.
What the hell?
That was a gorilla.
Why do you need that?
He didn't need that.
All right.
Yeah!
The reverse started.
Fight.
That was a good block.
Oh, he's so freaky and weird.
Really?
Yeah, counter hit.
Okay.
Like I know what to do.
I'm just not fucking doing it.
Yeah.
When that down two hits while sending four, he's mashing after it.
Yeah, okay.
That was very close.
That's the only adjustment you need, I think.
It's literally just that.
Round one.
Fight.
Not on counter hit though.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Round two.
Fight.
Not.
Woo!
Oh my god.
God, it's the sweet fucking thing.
Ah.
Damn.
Freaky.
Six.
Two.
Okay.
Nine.
Adapt, adapt.
Fight.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Yeah, Dragon is crazy.
Dragon is still bullshit.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know, man.
It's just fucking...
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
I had something and it's like...
I don't know.
That's alright.
We can run some drills.
Yeah.
It's no problem.
We gotta play Freaky Josh now.
Freaky.
Freaky ass Josh.
It's actually an entire freaky team.
It's just so hard to predict.
Our teammates will win this for us, guys.
I believe.
This is the second...
Is this team second or third?
Third.
Second.
Okay.
I think.
Yeah, this team is rebel-less.
Okay.
But they're tied, I think, for second though, if I'm not mistaken.
I think they're like one point above.
Is Kyle Delgado an AWP?
Yeah, I don't know who this guy is.
Nor do I know who Zin Megami Tensei is.
That's Josh.
I don't know who Kyle Delgado is.
Yeah, probably just like a streamer guy.
Yeah, just gotta kick him.
That's annoying.
Someone kick Kyle.
No one's gonna play you, bro.
Fuck ye.
Wait, what's the pass going?
1-9-1-9.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Like, everybody's seen the passcode already.
I bet you can see it in Sejam's stream too.
JoshmanReadyedUp is fucking stupid.
He's the stupidest person I think I've ever met.
In my whole life, ever.
Ranked.
Ranked number one on the PR.
Did someone leak the code?
The code is on screen.
Yeah, I was like, what does he mean?
Wait, Sejam actually hides the passcode?
Oh, it's our fault, I guess.
Not in my screen.
We all got a...
Oh, god.
And this is why he's secretly bald.
Do we actually have to hide the code?
Does Sejam want us to censor the code somehow?
I don't have the elements in my OBS.
Just get a picture.
Like, put a white bar on it.
I don't have the element.
Blackbar.png Yeah.
Wait, so what's happening?
How do I get in?
Brr.
Oh, I see, I see.
Alright, where are we going?
The Rage Art button, brother.
So Rage Art...
Remember, Slime, when he back ones, he generally likes to back one again right after, so you can maybe G-cliff that a couple times.
And then he's gonna start back one-ing into the 1-2 strings, which will beat your G-cliffs.
So if you're making the read, you can just hold back and be safe.
Or...
you can down back four for a huge call-out, because that'll crush the high, I think.
But, I mean, if you just hold back against Brian, he can only hit you with his hatchet.
And I guess, like, his...
wall stuff.
But, I mean...
depends on the stage.
For the wall stuff, pretty much, though.
Holding back, definitely more...
safe.
Yeah.
Yup.
Good luck.
The walls are good for you as well.
You got this.
Can Bear break floor easy?
Yeah.
Good shit.
Take him to the wall!
What a hot kick.
Oh.
Good shit.
Remember, when he's pressuring you, he bursts as a free get-out-of-jail card for you.
Okay.
Yeah!
No, did that mistake again.
Round 2.
Fight!
Dude, what?
Oh my god!
Back 2-2-1 with a combo.
Back 2-2-1.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, what?
Good shambler.
Oh my god!
Can't believe that connected.
Now this is bad.
It's okay.
Nice.
Good block, Josh.
Alright, no more cell sweeps.
Roll full crash down forward once, then it's safe.
Yup.
Good job.
I'm gonna finish that.
Oh.
Round 3.
Nice.
Fight!
Not breaking that in a hundred years.
He's making a lot of chip.
Nice!
Oh.
Bummer.
Damn, get off the floor.
I mean, your hits have a lot of damage though.
You don't have to worry about it anymore.
Yup.
He's gonna pop heat.
Probably blow heat smash by the way.
I'm just gonna chill.
Oh my god.
Good shit.
G-Klev doing work.
That's a little D-Klev.
Let's go.
Nice.
Good orbital, Josh.
Okay.
Nice.
Good shit.
Oh my god.
I can't see it yet.
Good job.
One more.
Woo!
Okay, that was sick though.
I just got to it.
Nice grab.
Nice fight.
What?
Oh.
Okay.
Wow.
Good shit.
Very electric.
He fucking broke the floor.
Another bounce.
Hell yeah.
Got him.
Look at that.
That full crouch.
Yeah!
Okay.
Full crouch down.
Good shit.
Thought I'd get crazy with it.
Nice orbital, Josh.
You're such a goat.
Runs in the room.
Fucking smacks you.
Nice grab.
No more autopilot.
How do I get up and block that?
I keep fucking... is that... is that true?
That might be real.
I'm not very clear.
I'm not sure.
We can lab it tonight.
You can hit up and down.
Oh beautiful.
I'm gonna see it soon.
Oh I saw it.
Sick combo.
Sick fucking combo.
Oh.
He's backing.
He's scared.
What?
Good duck.
Whoa.
Nice.
I'm seeing it.
Oh.
Nice.
Good job, Josh.
Guys, don't spoil the ending for me.
Does he win?
Not yet.
He said not yet locked in.
Good job.
I hate this fucking character in that fucking stupid move.
I fucking hate it.
That's a good move, yeah.
Oh.
Fuck.
Dude.
It's my fault.
It might kill me here.
This wall.
Yeah.
I'm gonna start command grabbing more.
He has no reason to duck after you're in HBS because you're not doing an HBS.
He's gonna take the grab after.
You know what I mean?
So that's why he's not ducking.
You have to threaten the hunting bear stance grab.
And you got this.
You got this in the set.
If you get the grab and break the floor, it's back 2-2-1.
He's just spamming that.
You can duck punish that, right?
You can duck it, yes.
He destroyed you.
Okay.
I'm synced back up.
Oh nice.
I fucking jabbed, dude.
I'm so annoyed.
And I rolled back into him.
Oh.
So close.
Nice.
Yeah, focus on your bear stance.
Nice!
Alright.
Got this.
What in the fuck?
There you go, bro.
Back 2-2-1.
There it is.
Back 2-2-1 and twice.
Nice.
That's fine.
There you go, bro.
You need that hunting bear stance.
That's gonna force your mix, dude.
There you go.
Good shit!
That's 2 in a row!
Final round.
Fight.
Oh, that was bad.
I gotta do the command grab.
Nice, orbital.
Hmm.
Winnable.
Very.
I think I'm dead here.
I dead-ass radar'd it too.
Aw.
That was close.
That's okay.
Last round.
Super close.
I mean like, final final, right?
Yeah.
I hate losing to him so much.
I fucking hate losing to Josh.
Oh, god.
Good news.
Definitely go to his room right now.
No.
The thing is, I would never pop off like he popped off.
That's the difference.
That's the Pepsi difference.
The Pepsi difference?
What's that?
He's so miserable to lose against.
Oh my god, I'm losing my mind.
Oh, he's giving me props?
That's really cool.
Was he giving me props when he went...
Pussy?
It's okay.
That's your...
Oh, I'm so mad.
This dude boxboxes hella random, bro.
What the fuck?
Yeah, you got a mission.
You haven't lost yet.
Come on, Matt.
You got to redeem us.
I got it, man.
I don't know dude.
This guy is so fucking random.
You say that every time and you win every time.
Yeah.
I don't know what's for Brian.
Cut.
Cool.
Yeah...
Whoa,
whoa, whoa!
Not that move, bro.
Okay...
Alright, that's one.
Round 2.
Fight!
Nice!
Yeah, that's crazy the dem links.
Oh my god.
This stage is a good Jax stage too.
So we got like good RNG?
Good rotation?
Yeah.
Nice.
Definitely.
Another rotation?
Oh, not fully.
You can rotate it.
Did you pick this stage on purpose?
Or was it random?
Oh shit.
Oh we blocked this.
Oh, I forgot that Asuka's bullshit!
We blocked it.
I just saw him block it.
Shit!
Okay.
Don't let us get swept!
Save us!
We still have Braum, bro!
We still have him!
Don't rely on me.
I'm coming off an L.
No way!
You'll lose.
That's too much damage.
Jesus!
There should be more because...
There's a wall there!
Oh my god!
That's the...
Honestly!
We need this.
Oh my god.
That was the Joe crush, bro!
Carry my ass!
I hate that trick so much.
You have no idea.
Oh my god, what?
Oh, really?
Okay, never do that to Bokoblins.
Yeah!
The FD Fire Slayer!
Yeah, he came back from that shit.
I'm gonna go back to the game.
Oh, fucking boxbox, bro.
What the fuck is he doing to you?
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Oh!
He's locking it in!
That's alright.
Scott, make it close.
See the delay?
Oh my god!
Yeah, that was a nice delay.
For his duck.
Oh, I can't game Jesus.
Gaming!
That shot was nuts!
If only King has missile hands, he'll be perfect.
He really reacts to that.
That's crazy for a New York player.
Jesus.
Don't let him stand up!
Keep him on the floor!
How does he do it?
Yeah!
Fucking insane, dude.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go!
Just when you think he's at his lowest!
He's a miracle!
Slightly more correct.
I'm gonna suddenly duck the grab.
Because I can't tick grabs.
We didn't get swept, guys!
Thank god.
Thank god!
Matt did it!
He saved us!
Always a miracle.
It's tough, man.
Yeah, man.
There's a reason they're top top right now.
They're right below us.
He was playing hella good too.
He wasn't optimizing, but he was doing pretty good.
Yeah.
Not good enough.
Too touching, man.
You guess wrong twice and you die.
Yeah.
Alright, we got our five points.
Yippee.
Yeah, good job, guys.
Oh, coach, you got this.
Redeem us too.
The sequel.
I'll just play my best.
Good shit.
Nice.
Dude!
Oh my god!
Take him to the wall!
Perfect!
He's pressing.
That's my fucking coach.
Oh my god.
Oh, you can't rage dart after that because he's mad.
Scary.
Yeah.
Come on!
Yes!
Good shit!
Nice.
Yes, sir!
Good shit!
Nice!
And there was an alley kick!
For the fans?
For the fans!
For the people in the back?
I've been hitting him with a lot of mids, so I'm surprised he's dunking.
It's because he sees King.
He always sees King.
He automatically ducks because of it.
That wall was...
Yeah.
But they can float the wall.
Fight!
Oh.
Oh, man.
That sucks.
The dick move!
That's right.
You got this, coach.
Yeah, you got the second set.
Look at the wall.
Nice.
Oh!
Good shit!
Oh, shit.
Oh, Jacey.
Oh!
Muscle buster!
The muscle buster!
Brian.
Freaky Brian.
Does that hurt?
Freaky Brian?
Does it hurt, Freaky Brian?
It's hard to hit confirm when that down forward 2 connects.
But it hits.
These guys are smoothing, man.
Yeah, he's like dancing.
Nice tackle.
It's like those YouTube videos that are like perfect.
It's in the wall.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Aww.
Dude, he's good at this.
Yeah.
I feel like he trained specifically against kings.
Oh!
Mario!
Yes!
I could not believe you got away with that.
Oh!
Fade back.
That's the mango.
Nice!
That's a lot.
That's a lot of damage.
Oh my god, the Jaguar run nothing?
This is too scary.
I can't.
Yeah, the sudden pause.
Oh!
Break his leg!
Break it, bro.
Sharp shooter.
Are you gonna rotate him?
There's been so many people rotated today.
Yeah.
The thing about Freaky Brian is he likes to...
Oh!
Big hopkick!
Nice!
Oh!
Should be everything.
Damn.
It's a hard combo.
Oh!
I wish I hit that.
Round four.
Fight!
Oh, he teched it.
Oh, Kingfisher mash.
Nice!
All the sidewall adjustment.
Yeah.
Sidewall adjustment is crazy here.
You're nuts.
My music fucking popping off.
I got Rebel Hanger final round playing.
Oh wow.
Woo!
Oh, that's scary.
Oh!
Nice try.
He's clutching.
Get him, Monk.
Get him, Monk!
Come on, coach!
Nice!
What a fucking dodge.
What?
This is a bad spot to be in.
Not the dick move.
Oh, that's...
No way!
Nice try.
Oh, nice try.
Oh my god.
He's very clutch.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Didn't get sweeped.
Hey, I did get sweeped.
Yeah, we needed that.
That was for the portal.
That guy is really good.
Fuck.
That guy was insane.
Let's just hope that one of the teams beat them.
I know Tone really, really, really wants to win too.
Like, he wanted me on his team and shit.
Like, he was like, hey, Matt.
Hey, Matt.
Wouldn't it be cool if you're on my team?
Woo!
Oh my gosh.
We're definitely gonna see them.
They're definitely getting one of the buys, I feel.
Oh yeah.
I think it's gonna be between us and MYK's team.
We're just trying to get the other one.
Yeah.
I fucking love that, dude.
That is the turtle tweet.
Oh my god.
That one was intense.
That felt like the finals.
Oh.
Did you guys see the...
Our team's over.
The Brawl Pro chat.
The Brawl Pro?
Our team chat.
Oh yeah.
In the fucking hilarious blind.
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
That was good.
Damn, losing kind of sucks.
Losing sucks, dude.
Oh my god.
That's why we're competitors.
That's why we lose now, so we get motivated to win.
You have so much advice in the chat and you just don't want to read any of it either, you know?
I know, because you want to walk in and shit.
Like, oh, go Paul.
Go Paul.
It's like, fuck, I do not feel like listening to this.
Now I know you're a streamer.
It's okay, guys.
That was the hardest team.
Now, like...
Now...
Now it's easy.
I literally just don't look at chat.
For the rest of my teammates.
I minimize the window.
I just play the game.
Now it's easy.
I got it.
It's for them.
I'm going to go for the perspective.
You know what?
That's true.
We got the hardest team out of the way.
The five alley kicks of the dream right here.
What the fuck, Shinru?
Isn't that higher than Garu?
What is she doing in my lobby?
I'm a baby!
Bro, I literally just fought ESAM.
Leave me alone.
Like...
Leave me the fuck alone!
I literally had to fight!
What the fuck?
Okay.
I got confused too.
I'm sorry.
Oh my god, please.
I had to fight ESAM.
Get out of my lobby!
Okay.
Oh god.
No!
Let's go team!
Alright, here we go.
God, they really fucked the vibes up.
Not really.
We got it.
The only thing is when winners lose, it's like...
It's like god...
It's like god is turning down his head.
It doesn't make sense.
What?
How did she sidestep that?
I'm fighting ESAM again!
It's going to happen eventually.
Go!
There's only so long you can go without fucking losing, dude.
I'm waiting for it.
Like I don't think it's going to be a big deal.
I don't care about it.
I think it's going to happen against FD.
You guys saw that fucking lag, dude.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I was going to lag against him.
I think it might be like a console issue or something.
Alright.
Like... that shit.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, how did I fuck that up?
How did I fuck that up?
Of course it's me.
Of course that's how I fuck it up.
Leave me alone!
Oh my god.
Please!
I just fought...
I just fought ESAM.
Get out!
Oh my god.
Get the fuck out of here.
I almost had it.
I did not almost had it.
You know that.
It's going to be hard.
No!
I don't want it to be harder!
I want to get it easily!
No epic!
I got three games from blue.
Oh you... Did you promote?
I'm close.
I'm halfway to purple.
If I could get blue before Sunday, I... you know.
That would feel nice.
I feel like you might as well just fucking strive for it.
That's easy.
Leave me alone!
Look at that.
You want to learn how to play Tekken?
You better play Tekken.
Please!
Leave me alone, please!
I have to fight ESAM!
Please leave me alone!
This is not fair.
This is actually not fair.
Bro, what the fuck are we doing here?
Mental shattered!
No!
I was waiting for blood to fight him!
What did he do to me?
Mental boomed.
He boomed the mental.
How?
How is this possible?
He just went free in my head.
Here we go.
I'm going to kill you.
Oh god.
Not a go.
There we go.
That should hit, right?
No!
How did that not hit?
There we go.
That should hit.
The ESAM curse.
Hey bro.
What's up?
I laughed at it before, but I honestly haven't done it.
I know that Oxy can literally let go of the rage art midway.
So it's not really a good sidewalk hit.
But if you are going to step it, is it left or right?
Bro, fuck off.
Pretty sure.
It's best to side step and then block.
So in case he does level 2, you can still launch that.
Yeah, yeah.
Fight!
Okay, this is the other combo.
He delayed getting up!
That my thing didn't even hit.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I didn't expect that.
Holy shit.
Is he going to duck?
No.
He didn't duck.
Thank god.
Oh thank god he didn't duck either.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh no.
Did I get up from that?
He missed!
Yes!
Okay, not intentional.
Wait, did I not get that point?
Did he unplug before?
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
I did not intentionally save that.
Oh!
But I'll take it.
I'll take it.
Oh thank god.
How did you do the forbidden?
I did the forbidden!
I didn't know I did it!
It's called button mashing.
I gotta stop.
Notification.
Get ready for the next battle!
Thank god for button mashing!
Uhhhh...
Did he actually play?
Yeah, I don't think it's up yet.
Oh, yep.
Bobby's up.
No!
I just got in a game!
Okay, I'll finish this rank match quick.
As in I'll lose really quick.
Round one.
Fight!
Alright, come on!
Yeah!
Boom!
Please let me win!
No!
Please!
Yes!
Okay.
When did this happen?
When did my neighbor get a drum sack?
What?
You're like, oh this is gonna be fun.
Moving forward.
Yeah.
Oh no no no no no no no no no.
He got his...
Oh sorry.
Sorry I had my mic on.
Oh, it's cool.
It's fun.
No!
Ahhh!
Okay.
Let's join.
No.
I'll be in in one second.
Oh my god.
He fucked up.
He fucked me up.
It's okay, I didn't want to be red anyway.
I didn't want to be red anyway, guys.
Oh my god.
Wait, he predicted that?
How?
How did he predict that?
My job is to beat Zhang Wei.
Let's go team.
I believe in all of you.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm not playing that well.
Don't worry about it.
It's okay, we lock in.
It's okay.
We all lock in.
Don't worry about it, man.
It's not even a start.
I'm rekt to raid!
Okay, I'm going in.
Let's go.
I'm rekt though!
Welcome, best fucking go.
I mean...
Best fucking go.
Goodbye, sir.
I'm locked in.
I got red.
Alright.
Where is the link?
I fucking had it.
Alright.
I had a crab.
It's fine if I lose or win.
I have red rings.
Don't worry, bp.
Honestly, like me too.
I feel like I'm playing like weird.
So, it's not even split.
Alright, guys.
For once in my life, I'll hide the passcode.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna do it, guys.
Doki, she's not even ranked that much higher than you, to be honest.
Very winnable.
Yeah, but I feel like she actually knows what she's doing because she played this game much longer.
I feel like she knows more than seven moves.
Alright, guys.
You can't blame me if somebody joins this lobby.
I actually hid the code.
It's not me this time.
Oh, you did?
I'm not putting in that much effort.
I'll say it.
I gave up.
Sajam has a toupee.
Like, the whole world's upside down.
What are these rumors, Slime?
It's not a rumor.
Everyone in the FGC knows this.
Knows what?
That Sajam has a toupee.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's real.
He's like Hitman bald.
Oh my god.
Why does he?
He values his hair so much.
I know.
Why does he care?
I...
If you're bald, you're smarter.
Because you mold so much.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Extra brain space, man.
His chat was probably making fun of him for being bald, so he went and got a toupee.
What do you think about the wolf?
It's good.
Didn't even rub it for good luck.
What do you think?
Avatar Aang is the goat, man.
Exactly.
He'd be crazy if I didn't care.
Bro, he's wearing a toupee because he's hiding his power.
That's why he's not a pro player.
I don't know.
That's the broccoli weight.
The toupee.
He can't be a pro.
He's not... He doesn't commit.
Oh man.
No wonder.
E-Sam is so good.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
No wonder he's so good because he's bald.
It's true.
Yeah.
E-Sam does get the weird bald buff.
I'm the best in the world at this.
What are we... what are we waiting for?
Y'all can go ahead and start?
Okay.
Fight!
Let me in!
SK is... SK is... oh we were waiting for...
Oh we were waiting, okay.
Oh he woke up, look.
He woke up.
I was like, who are we waiting for?
Finally, I can show the screen!
Let's go!
You can't yell at me guys!
If somebody joins the lobby...
Okay, but I hate playing as Rina though.
She's so fast.
She's so fucking fast.
I'm too bulky.
Just two reds duking it out.
That's what you love to see.
Honest red gaming.
This is true tech.
I proof forced this, right?
This is what I'm here for.
Wait, what was her weak... I don't remember what her weakness was.
Coach, you're the only one who knows.
You didn't tell me.
Coach, what do I do?
Run your shit!
Are we not talking about SK?
No, we didn't!
We never talked about SK!
Run your shit!
Let's go!
What do I do, coach?
That's your shit!
Wait, who's...
Right there, that!
Just do that!
Do what?
That!
You're playing it right now!
What's that?
This?
What are you doing?
Yup!
It's literally just happening.
It just happened.
You just did all of it.
I did that!
Fight!
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I did that!
Did you see that, coach?
Yeah, that was incredible.
Did she duck though?
Okay, I think she knows now.
She knows now, I feel like.
Time to use that mid.
Yup, time to hit the...
Oh wait, the square.
Yeah, when you're in the sprint.
Square.
It's okay.
It's time.
Oh my god.
There's no...
No fucking way.
We're not pressing down one time?
Not even once, huh?
What do you mean?
I told you, it's time.
Is there some kind of mental block against Doki Bird?
No one ever expects it!
Wait, she actually...
Oh, she's mixing it up.
Yeah, she's mixing it up.
Wow, smart player.
There's no way.
No!
What is this Doki Bird mental block?
I don't know, they never...
It's weird because they get it and then they lose it.
Yeah, I don't understand either.
I don't understand why they don't.
Oh my god, what are they doing?
Okay, both you and the slime and Kumi need to learn...
Take a book out of fucking Doki's face.
I know, right?
Rip that shit.
Alright, let's finish this.
Oh, she talked!
She talked!
Nice try, nice try.
Nice try.
Fight!
Oh, she's just like...
Okay, I was trying to, but then like...
Oh, fuck!
I tried to, but like I pressed square.
Okay.
Yes!
Oh god.
Oh, no, I couldn't...
Nice rage art.
No, she got it!
Oh, it's too strong.
Oh, the misery.
Wait, what?
Oh, good play.
Oh my god, I hate that move though in rank.
Oh, what?
Okay.
Hey.
Nice.
Okay.
I got it!
I got a set!
Let's go!
I did it!
Oh, that was close.
Good job, that was close.
25 hours Joki versus 100 hour Reina!
Who will win?
SK's definitely at 125 now.
Coffee baby versus Bob.
Yeah, I just did that.
Yeah!
Didn't your match hit the bell?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Nice.
You said you're five times better.
You don't want to see Doki Bird at 125 hours.
Yeah, you don't want to see 100...
I don't think I have the hours for that either.
To be fair.
Suplex?
Okay.
No way.
I like how you didn't hop kick either.
Yeah, that was good.
Oh my god, dude.
Guys, I feel like they're gonna learn this by the finals though.
It's looking like a pretty good move, bro.
I mean, I'm just saying, like, that was pretty good.
Oh my god.
Dude, that's so not good actually.
Dude, she's fucking swagging.
This is crazy.
Oh my god.
That's the new strength.
It's only correct decisions.
How did she keep getting away with this?
It's like God of War, she's buying new moves.
Like, Devil May Cry.
How did she keep getting away?
Oh, big dunk.
Oh no.
I don't know.
She like, fucking mixes it up, so it's hard.
Nice.
Oh no.
Goodbye.
She hits it.
Oh no!
That's fine.
She had to use lightning herself to kill you.
Just to be clear.
We start off with that.
Round start.
Alley kick.
You're about to get King's worst low nerfed.
Just because of what I do?
That's just because of Harada.
Harada's watching, I guarantee you right now.
Oh my god.
Do you think that was intentional for her?
That shit went like a movie.
Yeah, holy shit.
Okay, when you pop heat, hold onto your heat smash.
Don't pop it right away because she's blocking it.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh, I think she actually is learning.
Yeah, that was a good adaptation.
We're still live.
Oh my gosh.
Boom.
Do I do square or grab?
You run up grab.
Okay.
Wait till she gets up though.
Wait till she gets up.
Because sometimes they like to stay on the ground.
There you go.
I pop heat.
And go mid.
Square, square.
Bad read Matt!
Oh nice try, nice try.
Bad read!
A plan is better than no plan at all.
It's Matt's fault.
Yeah, you blew it for us.
I can only be right so many times, I'm sorry.
The wrong read.
Okay, do that running grab a lot.
She has not picked a single one.
And then she's gonna...
And then she's gonna do a bad read again.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
She mad.
She mad now.
She fucking mad now.
She's fucking mad.
Oh my god.
She's so mad.
I'm so sorry.
She's gonna block this.
Alright, true, true, true.
You said it all there.
Round two.
Fight!
Okay.
Oh.
I like the idea.
We're playing Tekken.
We're playing Tekken, yeah, right here.
Right now.
This is Tekken.
Oh shit.
Yeah, this is definitely Tekken.
Nice, I love your patience.
It's so good.
I think I need to be more patient, guys.
Oh, huge.
No, what?
No, she actually blocked it.
It's okay.
And in the end, I got that one set.
Not over.
That's true.
Wait, what?
What was that?
I don't know.
Yeah, that looked fucking freaky though.
Freaking technique though.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a freaky fucking technique.
Oh fuck, I should have grabbed.
Nice.
Guys, it's okay.
I got us that five points though.
You got...
Wait, we get points per game?
Do we get per set?
No.
Oh, we don't this time?
No!
No, I should have used more alley kicks.
I blame Matt.
Alley kicks probably would have made her knees explode.
True.
She would have been a smoking pair of shoes in the coliseum.
So true.
What's the code for this lobby?
It doesn't let me spectate, so I restart it.
How do I say it to you without leaking?
It's 8921.
Oh, I guess it doesn't matter yet.
We did this fucking yesterday.
I'm so stupid.
Oh god.
Right there.
Who's next?
Kony.
He will not play R2.
Let's go Kony.
I should have alley kicked more.
Let's go GOAT.
Let's go GOAT!
Come out Kony.
Bring it back.
Redeem me.
Oh, I got a good stage.
It's the comet.
Asteroid, whatever it is.
Floor blast on the third round.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she's always going to start off with that sidestep.
Round one.
Shoulder.
I hate fighting her, Rink.
Yeah, she can be enemy.
Oh.
Got it.
Island Kony.
Come out Kony.
The Bahamas.
Nice!
Round two.
The coach didn't teach her that.
They will by the tournament time.
Yeah, definitely.
You think they're using you.
You're so cute right now.
Whoa.
Yeah, I'm just going to abuse that.
Oh my god.
That's just our layer one.
So that's okay.
Right.
I tried to go the muscle buster.
Yeah, it would have exploded the wall.
Nice.
I'm going to go the force.
That's what I'm trying to land here.
I don't want to try to force it too much though.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, she broke it.
Wow.
Got it.
It's a pressing button.
That was insane.
Oh, sorry.
I got it.
If she's smart, she'll switch the techniques.
Yeah, you can.
I mean, I didn't earlier.
Has anyone actually swapped a stage?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I think we're just autopiling on this.
I would.
I would just be like, yeah, rematch, go again.
I lose, I win, alright.
Alright, Matt, but you didn't.
You never lost.
I will eventually.
You don't need to swap stages.
You don't lose.
Yeah.
Nice.
Got it.
Let's go.
Down back three, baby, down back three.
She's just really scared.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
So I can just control pace.
Oh my goodness.
I'm gonna do that to Eski in the finals.
Yup.
Oh, she doesn't take Drain Swing.
Oh.
Oh my god, bro, you're nuts.
If she's struggling to me now, it's Ali kicks.
It's just like, like she's scrambling to find an opening.
So if I just swing every time, it's like, I don't know.
I think her brain scrambled.
Yeah, there's no boxes going on.
This matchup's very annoying, so I get it.
Or not the matchup, but I guess King.
Yeah, King's a nut.
Shit.
She's breaking everything.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's breaking.
A counter hit throws, too.
Is she mashing or is she actually knowing the tech?
Well, she's broken both twos and threes.
Or twos and ones, so.
And this might be...
She's on one plus two.
Nice job.
Alright.
It won't be that fee in finals, but I appreciate the points.
Lightweight, baby.
Yeah, fee has to teach her that, like, that should not hit.
Like, just lay down, you know?
Alright.
Let me read my first one.
Alright, fang notes.
Fang way.
This guy is good.
I believe in you.
Oh, wait.
Was it this guy?
I think it was this guy, right?
Or am I thinking of Rey?
Fairlight is the fang who is pretty hard.
Okay.
We talked about it.
And remember, Slime, he's going to lay down in a lot of okey situations when he liked to do the running one plus two.
So that's a forward forward two.
Yep.
Don't start the round with buttons.
He's always waiting for you.
Okay.
Maybe you can start with like a down back two.
Maybe.
If you really want.
And back one plus two.
Hunting Bear stands one plus two will probably get this guy.
Look at the cause.
How do I get in there?
Who is unban me brawl co- Who the fuck is that?
How are they getting in here?
I'm unbanning you.
That's so cringe.
Okay.
That's not from me.
I want you to know that.
You will never be valued from the people that you watch every day ever.
Oh my god.
Remember that.
Well we know the leak is not coming from us for sure.
It's coming from inside the Brawl Pro chat.
Yeah.
It's actually our alt accounts by the way.
It's one of us.
I like at least he's sitting on the sidelines.
Yeah he's not hopping in.
Holding the lobby hostage.
He's making a statement.
Alright.
Let's do it baby.
Oh that's a new costume.
Is that the Punisher?
Oh my god he has a gun.
Maybe he's Jason.
There's that snake edge.
Oh this guy is a nerd.
I gotta stop doing that.
Stop messing it up.
I didn't mean to do that.
Nice job.
Way careful.
Alright time to mix it.
Time to mix it.
I waited.
Deal.
Oh my god.
Aww.
Deal.
What the fuck?
Where did your HP go?
I got a two grab.
That's a one or two.
You could have killed him if you did the wall combo.
Yeah.
KO.
Fight.
Okay we got this.
Take this.
Oh my god.
There it is.
I'll get in charge of it.
That's okay.
Good shit.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh jigglet didn't work.
Fight.
Jesus.
No.
I thought he would do a low.
He just kept doing the running one.
Can I step that?
If I know what's coming.
Yeah.
But if he hits you with it and it knocks you down and then you tech then probably not.
He just shouldn't do that pose.
When he's TOing I mean if you can react to it and you block that you can twin piston it.
Okay.
TO is really bad.
That shoulder.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh my god.
Grab the threat and the punting bearer.
Grab.
Oh.
I'm really tired man.
I can't fucking...
Alright.
Let's play the game.
He's definitely overwhelming for sure.
That was sick.
You can also... that roll guard break remember?
No way.
I would definitely rage art him after he does something like that.
Like a heat burst.
Yeah.
You have it.
He's mashing every time.
Oops.
I'm gonna go for the headshot.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's breaking 1 plus 2 every time.
Oh.
The punish.
Oh my god.
Go slam.
Not yet.
Oh.
Nice.
Yo.
Oh.
Kuma.
Good dive.
Fight.
How did that work?
Tio.
Boom.
Always grabbing from Oki.
Oh wow.
Just a tuck in.
I didn't know he could do another fucking kick.
What a fucking miserable character.
What a fucking miserable fucking character.
He's a strong player.
Yeah.
He's good.
Sounds off of me.
Like why would you play the character that does that pose?
For real, bro.
I was thinking of last match.
I was thinking that.
That makes you think.
Like what are you really about, man?
Yeah.
I wasn't gonna say anything.
But if you're gonna say it...
That's all.
Are they updating the points live or...
Probably not.
Right?
Got you.
I'm laggy as fuck, Eddy Zafina.
I'm gonna say it like I'll definitely try but I...
Like this guy...
He's playing on a microwave, man.
I don't know.
We'll try.
It's okay.
If you're lagging, he's lagging.
This is like literally the most ranked Tekken match I've ever experienced.
Like, one bar Eddy...
Jack!
Oh no!
He said fuck your character.
What?
I saw him in the general last night.
He said this was gonna be a jack off.
Oh my god.
I'm not kidding.
He said he was gonna learn Jack off first.
Jack off.
Yes.
That's what he said.
Chat, is this real?
Oh my god.
The Jack mirror?
Did he give up?
No.
He played Jack.
He's not the undertaker, bro.
Oh, that is the undertaker.
Father Gascoigne.
Bloodborne.
Whatever his name is.
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
A Jack off.
Okay, don't do that.
Understood.
He's gone out there jacking off.
He's jacking it?
Wait, what do you guys mean by that?
What?
It's when you...
Yeah, who?
You know, in the race of Jacks.
Oh, oh.
What were you thinking about?
You?
Nice.
Water Raid.
Jack him harder!
Okay, believe me.
No, it's true.
He's gotta jack as hard as he can.
You can't look him in the eyes!
If you keep jacking this hard, somebody's gonna start a fire.
You gotta look him in the eyes!
Friction.
Oh, we're distracting him.
We should stop.
Round three.
Maybe.
Nice duck.
Woo!
Fuck yeah, counter hit.
Blue spark, everything.
Dong, dong, dong.
Yeah!
Oh, that was sick.
That's so good.
Yeah.
That was sick.
You're spanking a lot.
Ooh.
Damn, the double jacks, man.
No way.
Ooh!
Oh.
Nice!
Let's go!
Counter hit, dude.
Get back on Eddie.
Get back on Eddie!
I'm throwing a set away!
Thank you.
I'm throwing the set away.
Alright, yeah, leave the lobby.
Alright.
We're gonna change.
Don't do that.
I know, I know, like, you got a lot of Tekken experience under your years and shit, but in a new game, just play Eddie.
I wanna fight.
What the fuck?
I don't know why you picked Jack on me, man.
Well, remember when we were gonna bot review him?
I know, right?
I thought Jack would play.
He did play Jack, yeah.
He's got a very legacy Jack.
Not a single gamma hell.
Yeah, he didn't do a DZ check, bro.
Oh my fucking god, I hate this guy.
Alright, Brawl Pro, I actually need your help.
Next round.
Oh, Savina.
Oh, remember that power crush?
Oh shit, thank you.
So you pressure him?
You can, yeah.
Okay.
Savina?
Why do they play such freaky characters?
I've not seen this before.
Dude, she's so freaky.
Watch, watch.
She'll get on the ground.
It's a freak festival.
Is it the one where she climbs on, like, a spider?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bro, I hate you.
Okay.
Oh.
Uh oh.
Oh my god.
Good shit.
What a genius.
Nice.
Ooh!
Send him to space, Jack.
You're going into orbit.
Hahaha.
Round two.
Fight.
That's not fair.
Hahaha.
Spamming is banned.
Somebody should tell him.
No, no, no.
We...
Alley kicks have been paying us.
No, no, no.
We need the alley kicks.
I almost beat SK on alley kicks alone.
Hahaha.
The fact that it worked, like, not once, but three times in a row was what surprised me.
What is she doing?
If she had a fist on her head, she would die.
Hahaha.
Why is she doing that?
That is not an advantageous position.
Like a watermelon.
Ooh.
She weighs, like, 110 pounds.
Hahaha.
Alright, never mind.
I'm not afraid of Zav.
We get one punch.
Let's go.
58 defense, my go 58 defense.
58.
That's two, right?
I don't have to fight again?
What do you do?
Well, there's one more.
One more season.
Yeah, you won two.
Yeah, sorry.
So I'm good.
I leave?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, alright.
Dude, if I lose a third Koja match, I need a therapy session.
Okay, I will give you the biggest hug at EVO.
We're gonna be there anyway.
Don't worry about it.
It's alright.
Let's all get dinner, bro.
Let's go to EVO.
I want to.
I was trying to figure out, like, a good fucking dinner spot.
So I was gonna hit you guys up.
Be like, hey, you wanna...
Where is EVO this year?
Yeah, I'm down, dude.
It's in EVO every year.
Doki.
I don't know.
Are we gonna win?
Oh, you know.
I think I love that response.
That is good.
Supers... I think he's gonna go too.
So we should invite him to dinner.
Yeah.
You got this, my goat, my uncle, my dad, my everything.
Come on, coach.
This is it.
Gotta bring it home.
That's right.
I'll study up for the tourney.
Like on the... in two days from now.
I see my mistakes.
Like, they'll duck like I grab and then I'll lose like half my life.
And then they'll...
situation me and then...
It's rough out here, man.
These guys are good.
How did he improve so fast?
I don't understand.
Steve this time?
You're supposed to stop.
Alright, I'm gonna close my chat.
Steven?
We'll be your chat.
Don't worry.
Is that Bayonetta on Steve?
Yeah.
That's Steven.
Bayonetta and gender bend.
Fight.
Mm-hmm.
Damn it.
Oh, it's Kojima!
Oh, maybe.
Kojima doesn't wear pajama bottoms.
Oh, no.
Kojima on break.
Good shit.
I like the little push.
Nice.
What the fuck I'm talking about, baby?
Oh, yeah.
I'm not sure.
Round three.
Four.
Damn.
Oh.
Freaky, Steve.
I'll say it.
It's just us against the freaky army.
That's it.
Every team just studied our gameplay only.
It's a world of degenerates.
It's a world
of degenerates.
It's a world of degenerates.
Shit.
Oh, nice.
Nice?
Okay.
Kojima in the nut.
Oh!
Good shit.
Nice.
I love how it's like chicken playing chicken right now.
Let's go.
Good shit.
Alley kick, baby.
Hell, yeah.
Good ass move.
We get distributions from big alley kick.
Yeah.
The alley kick clutch.
That's a wall, Steven.
Take him to that wall.
Bro is counting.
One, two, three.
One, two, three, four.
Oh.
Nice.
How does it fucking move?
We need this.
Ouch.
What the fuck?
Low parry?
How, dude?
What was that move?
That move hit the end?
Ow.
It would hurt.
Blood is a boxer.
They don't do that shit in his ring.
Come on.
My overall is attacking.
Go, baby.
I don't even know what this move is.
Take that.
Maybe one of these.
Oh.
It's like a chiropractor.
I'm just gonna make a little adjustment.
You guys.
Nice.
This guy is not playing around anymore.
He keeps saying that.
Oh, what?
That was a clinch.
It doesn't matter.
Give me some three heads in chat.
Up out.
Done.
One, two, three.
He.
Beans.
Sausage.
Smash.
Oh my god.
I'm saved.
Simple as.
Oh, no way.
That was so weird.
Oh, good.
Oh, no.
Push.
Get up, coach.
Oh, man.
Wow.
That was so sick.
Oh my god.
That was good from him.
Yeah.
Fight.
Oh, nice.
I'm so fucking funny that that's his optimal look.
He's so clean with the float.
He's doing it.
Buddy.
Nice.
Okay.
One more.
That's for your life.
Good shit.
Good shit, bro, bro.
I love you, Unc.
Let's get this done.
Oh, look at all these blocks.
Smash.
Nice.
Yeah.
Bust his ass.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
Oh, yes.
Oh, take him to the wall.
Yes.
Real freaky hours.
We're in the basement now.
It's wall time.
What am I getting the wall?
Yes.
Call him wall pro.
Oh, he blocked that?
Yeah, he has to rest a little.
He's got no clutch bone.
No clutch bone.
What the fuck did he just do?
Oh, I pressed.
No.
Nice try.
That was a nice try.
That was a good rage art.
Yeah.
That was good.
That was a really good rage art.
That was a good fight, though.
That was good.
Yeah.
That was a really good match.
Woo.
That match was insane.
Download.
He's only 26, Daniel.
You're 100 Daniels.
Come on, you win this, you'll be 120 Daniels.
You steal his Daniels.
Yeah.
Those Daniels need a new home.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Nice break.
That was unfortunate.
Round two.
Oh.
Damn.
Nice.
Oh.
Shit.
Oh my god.
Those ducks.
Let's go.
It's like he actually knows how to play Tekken.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh my god, that camera.
Oh, double.
It's his alley kick.
His brain is scrambled.
No one knows what to do.
Do it again.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I think he's scrambled, bro.
Take it home.
He saw what I did to SK and he got worried.
His brain is hot right now.
Oh, whoa.
That was a good sidestep.
Nice.
Yeah, he's not done yet.
Hm.
Nice.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Yeah.
Yes.
The bomb.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go, coach.
Yes.
Take the win.
That's what you thought.
Good shit, dude.
Oh, not even close.
It's because he used to play Melee.
Yeah, true.
He's got that actual unbreakable monkey.
Okay, his name is Brawl Bro to be clear.
Guys, we gotta...
I think we claim him.
We gotta congratulate him on his first win today.
His first win.
Let's go, coach.
Welcome to the club.
Join the club.
Join the winner's club.
Good fucking shit.
Nice job.
Hey, we kinda did well.
Yeah, we fucking... we were cooking.
3-2, not bad.
We take those.
Positive record, especially, you know, 5 points per.
That's big.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Yeah, we're looking good so far.
Because we did 4-1.
Let me see.
4-1.
1-4, but then 3-2.
So we're in a good spot.
I think...
Also, we got the hardest team out of the way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't say that.
You're gonna carve us, bro.
The hardest team for you.
I think that's true.
I think Matt's just like, all teams are the same.
I got all demons every single day of my life.
I'm fighting them, I'm falling asleep.
And you beat them all.
You haven't lost yet, Jack.
Dude, I will be losing.
You've literally been saying that for two slams.
It's his strat.
It's like his reverse jinx.
It's actually impossible for me to lose.
Because if I lose, then I'll say, yeah, I told you guys I would lose.
But if I don't, then I look like a fucking god.
You laugh at this.
But yeah, I'll be losing soon.
Don't say that.
Because what if that happens in the finals?
Dude, because Scarra is hella random.
We got Scarra and Amaz.
You guys saw how they were playing.
Armor, hopkick, armor, dick jab.
Every defensive option ever.
I gotta make a read on what the fuck they're gonna do.
You guys read?
Not me, man.
I brain rot away playing Overwatch.
And Tekken.
Do we have a while until the next one?
Yeah, do we have a while?
Not sure.
I'm gonna go get some water and use the bathroom.
Little refresher.
Alright.
Time to practice Tekken.
Oh my god,
I'm playing as a Tenryu now.
I'm too high rank.
I don't belong here.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't belong in this elo.
I literally lucked out on this elo.
I brute forced my way into this elo.
Literally, I have not been playing that much Tekken.
I'm pretty... I don't think I belong here.
I don't think I belong here.
Oh no, please leave me alone.
I don't even know how to juggle!
That's how I don't belong here!
I don't even know how to juggle people!
Yay!
Whoops, that was an accident.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Here you go.
Yay!
Curried by alley kicks!
Bro, some people spend their entire lives fucking grinding to this elo.
I don't know how I get here.
That's the saddest part.
Some people spend their entire lives getting here.
I just existed.
I alley kicked my way to victory.
I think, like, including the games now, I think I have 30 hours on Tekken.
30 hours on Tekken for a red rank.
It just works!
Just don't kill it!
Told you, I don't belong here!
Don't kill it!
The moment I learned a 5th and 6th move, I went up two ranks.
Like, yesterday I was at, I think, Dominator?
I think yesterday I was at Dominator.
I think I started at Dominator or something.
Right?
And then in like...
And then when I learned the 5th and 6th move, I went up to red.
So like...
Every move unlocks a rank!
She keeps getting away!
I don't know how!
I don't know how I keep doing it.
It's actually crazy.
Like, I literally don't know what I'm doing.
Like...
I should not be getting away with this.
Is this the same guy?
Is it?
I'm sorry, bro.
Bro, get your rank back!
Natural instinct!
Bro, I'd be mad!
Like...
I'd understand!
Oh shit.
Bro, I think he's angry that I tried to one and done him.
Yeah, he's definitely...
Guys, I think he's angry.
I'm pretty sure he's angry.
I'd be angry too, not gonna lie.
Yeah!
Oh, he actually defended that.
Please!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Fight!
I'm sorry!
Wait, he actually blocked those?
That's when you know he's like an actual gamer.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
He sidestepped!
He actually knows what he's doing!
I literally got here as a fluke!
He got his elo back!
He figured me out!
Okay.
This is why I won and done people.
Because they figured it out by the second game.
Alright, here I go!
Where's the lobby at?
There it is.
I'm joining, I'm joining.
Alright guys, I'm gonna hide the passcode.
So it's not my fault.
Alright, guys it's 2250.
Alright, here I am.
Guys, I think this guy learned though.
The Har... Har... what's his name again?
The LoganRDJ guy, I'm pretty sure he learned how to counter me.
Okay, back, okay, back.
I'm pretty sure.
I abused so many moves on him.
So we are hiding the thingamajig?
If you so desire to do so...
Uncle, you may.
They're asking if we're ready.
But none of you guys are in here.
They're asking if you're ready.
But none of you are in here.
I'm about to join.
Literally, the only person I see is Slime.
Slime is the only person here with me.
I'm a good egg.
I'm a good eye.
We're gonna starve without Kony, I guess.
I'm coming in, I'm coming in, I'm coming in.
Sorry.
I'm finishing my match too, sorry.
After this, I need to use the bathroom.
Gotta hurry.
Oh my god.
They kicked out Logan.
Alright, I'm in.
Yippee.
Alright, we got this.
This is your time.
This is it.
Wait, he didn't rank up.
You're actually the same rank as this guy.
Yeah.
Why didn't this guy rank up?
Not have a grind set.
No grind set like you.
What?
This guy started like a week earlier than me.
And I caught up in three days.
How's that possible?
Here I go.
It's okay.
If I lose, it's okay.
It's all about the experience.
And I know my team is...
My teammates got me.
Got you, dog.
Waiting for opponent.
What do you have to pick?
Get ready for the next battle.
Probably the stage.
Waiting for the good random.
Maybe he was timing it.
He can time it?
Oh my god, it's One Punch Man!
Oh, he's serious now.
I love One Piece.
He's actually serious.
Okay.
How's that coach staying on, bro?
Oh my god.
He's so...
He's a kicking guy.
He's actually serious now.
Yeah, that's true.
It doesn't make sense.
And it's not one kick.
It's a great many.
He already fucked it up.
How did he...
Oh my god.
I did it.
So good.
Yay!
That roar with the game was synced up on my screen.
It was very cool.
I want you to know that.
Someone clip that, please.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think he actually learned though.
Three.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
I should have done more alley kicks.
It's only hop kick on five.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Yeah, let's go for a grab or something after.
Oh, he ducks now.
I think like after what I did to him, he's got... he like learned.
What a dog.
It's Shane duck.
Yes.
Oh, cooky.
Yay!
Boom.
That's it.
Nice.
Nice!
Oh, you're a legend.
You're a fucking legend.
Good shit.
Fight.
Unbelievably nuts.
Oh, shit.
He doesn't do that thing that abused him last time, you know?
Remember?
Yeah, that string.
Yeah.
He doesn't do that anymore because I think he got tilted with that.
Wait, what?
It didn't hit?
What?
The timing was crazy.
It worked?
On purpose.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
He was ready for that.
Yeah.
Fight.
Woo!
Not that one.
That wasn't actually it?
What?
Oh, no.
He got me.
Wha... what?
How does he do that?
It doesn't give a crap.
Not with square.
Oh!
What do I do?
Never mind.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Nice try.
Good try.
He figured me out!
He downloaded me from yesterday.
Or two days ago.
And now we download back!
Okay, what do I do?
Now we beat his ass!
What do I do?
When he knocks you down, just hold back and get up instead of getting up with a bunch of 1, 2, 3, 4 buttons.
Just get up with back and just hold back.
If he knocks you down.
Oh my god.
He definitely trained against the king.
He did not like that.
Yeah, he definitely played against a lot of kings.
Good heavens.
You don't have to get up either.
You can stay grounded if you want.
Oh, I should?
Should I?
Yeah, yeah.
Against this guy, yeah.
I feel like I'm gonna get knocked down.
I feel like I should.
Yeah, this guy.
Oh.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Good stuff?
Oh, what the fuck?
How did that work?
How come that didn't work?
He ducked it.
He actually ducks?
Yeah.
He's mixing it up.
So you run into him and do the knee to mix it up.
Okay.
Remember that running knee.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's black.
All right.
Well, it worked.
Yay!
That's good.
Oh no.
What a break.
Yup.
Oh.
Okay.
Cooked.
Yay.
That's counter hit.
Oh my god.
Oh, what?
Oh, he sidestepped.
It's okay.
Focus, focus.
Oh, he sidestepped me.
Still alive.
Did I hit those?
Yeah!
Let's fucking go.
Nice job.
Yeah!
Good shit.
Oh my god.
I hit it.
Good shit.
I hit those.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I should...
I need to do the square.
Yeah, the square.
Yeah.
Because he's a square.
Yup.
That's right.
Oh, he's a square.
Yup.
Boom!
Oh he ducks it now!
He blocks it!
You told me nobody blocks this you liar!
Nice try.
Is that alright?
He actually learned from me.
That's just raw adaptation and a skull necklace.
That's true.
He was one punch man.
How the fuck do I kill that guy?
I don't think we can.
Yeah!
I'm gonna use the Batdune.
You got this Kony!
Do what I couldn't do!
Wait Doki you have to hit the rage button before you leave.
I got you.
Thank you.
That was fun.
Let's get it brother.
I hate this stage.
It's for you.
Oh grabs.
Okay.
Lots of grabs.
Do it again.
Okay.
Lots of grabs.
I got it.
Oh.
Oh wow.
Big counter hit.
What the hell.
Nice.
Good play.
That comes back so far.
You forward 2-1 that if you block that.
Okay.
Damn.
They all train against kings.
Got it.
That was sick.
Wow.
What a swing.
Nice job.
Start off with Kankans.
My guess is she is starting with Kankans because her coach told her to go the low on Power Crush.
Do you have them pulled off?
No.
Just a guess.
Okay.
That would be crazy intelligence.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Hit her out of that.
That's crazy.
Angleslam.
Nice!
Fuck!
I thought she was dead.
Yeah, shit.
I didn't press anything.
Yeah, it's free after angle slam.
She has Hadouken as well, so be careful.
No, she lost her heat though.
She doesn't have heat.
Oh, I'm looking at the other fucking guy.
Sorry.
You're looking at her teammate!
Oh my god, I punched.
Alright.
Got it.
Nice!
Jab!
Jab jab.
Apparently, so much chat said like, this team actually exclusively trained against Kings.
That makes sense.
And where is it getting them?
Like, let's be real here.
Oh, how did...
Oh, nice!
I know, I didn't think of that in time.
Doki bird.
Doki bird special.
They never trained against this, so...
Almost.
Good job.
Nice quick punish.
What the fuck?
Alley kick is free there.
Alley kick...
Oh fuck, you're right.
Sorry.
Nice job.
Nice!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Let's go.
They might have beat my king, but they haven't beat Kony's king.
Coach Kony!
You can't download him.
He's can canning.
There it is!
Oh!
She's scrambling out of block.
Our beautiful, beautiful patient man.
Yeah.
Not a good reaction time.
No.
No, no.
What the fuck I'm talking about dude?
I remember.
That was unreal dude.
That's okay.
Alley kick?
Fuck it.
Nice!
She's scrambling.
She's nervous.
He lost it.
Just fine.
The snowballer.
He looked at the wrong king to train against.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Grab.
I was gonna say, because her coach definitely told her to grab first, so...
I'm expecting grab on run up, but...
I'm trying too hard.
Because I feel like she's back there, and I'm trying to chase her.
You can forward 2-1 that if she blocks that.
Right, right, right.
The chase.
The backflip thingy she had.
Okay, shiny wizard now.
Yes!
All good, all good.
Nice.
Good.
Boom.
Wall?
Oh!
Take her to that wall!
Guaranteed guaranteed wall.
5, 6, 7, how long can you go?
And he'll wake up.
Do it, do it again, do it again!
Yeah!
Dude.
Alright, just pressure bro.
Just pressure.
But he's a real anchor here, man.
Bro, you should've kept going.
You should've kept going until she stopped.
Just keep alley kicking?
Yes!
100 alley kicks!
And plus 1 alley kick.
Do it again.
You could've done it.
Nice job, nice job.
Alright, freaky Jin time.
I taught him that.
I taught him the alley kick.
Well, slime.
It's your turn.
Get me in there.
Well, Coney also has to...
Yeah, there it is.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh man.
Can you imagine if this was a Street Fighter slam and like the team had like 3 Zangiefs?
Yeah, right?
It's so goofy.
That team would lose.
Badly.
Yeah, exactly.
Is that like the King equivalent?
No, he's a grappler.
He's a grappler in Street Fighter.
Actually, I don't know.
I feel like low level Zangief, especially on Modern, like a Guile's not gonna know what to do.
Like a first week Guile, you know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
Same stage as last time.
It's fun.
Tell them to get a Street Fighter.
Three Hondas would fu..
Yeah, Honda is a better.
Honda would fuck people up in a Street Fighter slam.
That character is annoying if you're new.
Round 1.
Good shit.
Make a presence.
Nice.
Download him.
Here
we go.
I was gonna die.
Really?
Oh no.
He's gonna die.
Oh!
I mean, do that butt this works.
Close though!
I didn't think I'd launch on that.
The butt would have been guaranteed.
Oh, nice.
Look at the chip.
Jesus!
Oh, jeez!
Wow.
He got up wrong.
I thought he knew it.
Nice!
Fight!
Oh, God.
That was a fun test then.
Smack him.
Okay.
That was good punish by that guy.
Makes sense.
Nice job.
Is that a troop?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's...
Oh, my God.
He has the main character buff.
That's not fair.
Why does this fucking launch?
What is this shit?
Listen.
He's also using fight.
I'm trying to do it.
He's doing this to one four and it's like that.
Hi, mid mid.
It's like two punches on a kick.
He keeps counter hitting you.
That's it.
No.
If he delays it.
Yeah.
But he's not delaying it.
Round.
One.
Fight.
That.
That move.
Yeah, that.
Oh!
I'm bad, I'm bad.
Sorry, you'll get used to it.
He plays like a bot.
Like a fucking AI made to play games online.
This is what I said, remember two days ago?
He just plays like the most regular Tekken you've ever fucking seen.
Yeah, so like he takes it really slow, right?
Yeah, he's not...
doing it a lot.
Nice!
Nice punish.
Yeah.
Oh!
That's what we're talking about, baby!
Oh, guaranteed.
That's crazy.
Nice!
All good, you got a big lead.
Oh my god!
What a timing.
What?
Dude, I hate this fucking combo.
Remember, you have a heat.
Just burst if it's like the end of the round.
Yeah.
How does that fucking happen, dude?
I'm holding back.
I'm just gonna...
Alright,
good start.
1, 4, 2...
I'm breaking these.
I knew I was gonna die here.
God, what a bot.
Ugh.
I'll be a nice person in real life.
I fucking hope so.
I think so.
Sean's late.
But Jen is strong.
No, no... I'm just not blocking.
I'm just fucking terrible.
He gave you a lot of cookies he whipped...
a few times.
Okay.
It's okay, Matt.
Matt takes it home for us.
Okay, I'm actually losing this one.
I'm not even kidding- This is the most random fucking play I've ever played in my life.
Jesus, a religion started because of him!
Oh, no, no.
You're the only one who can!
What the fuck?
I'm speed... oh my god, zoom!
Oh, interesting.
What the fuck?
Brrrr!
Let's get it.
New in-chain song.
Oh my god.
What's cool?
That's the meta lead.
Fuck.
Whoa.
How do I turn the end?
What happened in history?
L2.
Thanks.
No way.
Nice.
Yeah!
What the fuck happened to my armor?
You pressed, you had to hold it.
Fuck.
Nah, I mean, I should have canceled it in public.
It didn't come out.
It's alright, GOAT.
It's alright.
It's okay, it's okay.
Just one set.
A lot of these strings have these highs in them.
That if you knew about them, you could...
Like her 1-1, her 10 frame punish is a high high.
Also, there's two hits that go into chainsaws.
She only...
Well, I mean, I can't explain it now, but...
Just know there are gaps.
Good block.
Oh my god, I hate this guy.
Wow, again.
Yeah, let's bait out the hopkick then.
Boom.
Nice.
What is that move?
I know, fuck Alyssa.
I hate playing against Jade.
Okay.
Let's get it.
Nice.
Big.
Big hit.
Take your chance.
Let's get to the more.
Oh, he doesn't know.
Nice.
Yes.
That string, that's a high.
Okay.
I literally just don't know the string.
Nice.
Last hit on the board.
Not close at all.
Oh, what the fuck, man.
What the fuck this character?
I mean that's green but even... Even this, this is gonna scale too cause Alyssa's always in the air.
Wait, really?
That's crazy.
That's so dumb.
Nice!
Oh nice!
Also in the air.
What the fuck?
Uh oh.
Wait what happened?
I tried to blast off.
The patriot fist?
Okay yeah if I'm not doing this then I'm not doing well.
Oh it's over for me Burrows.
No!
I feel it.
You turned us around!
I'm dead bro.
Yeah yeah.
Good try man.
I made it.
Nooo let's try.
You know what?
We got the loss out of the way.
We got it out of the way.
You like this kind of stuff.
Like this team hard trained against us so it makes sense you know.
Although the streak is over, that gives us a chance to start a new streak.
That's right.
A better one.
There it is.
It was even longer.
Yeah.
And then look at this shit.
Another fucking Alyssa.
It's gonna go all the way to Evo.
Makes you think.
I can't believe it.
They went anti-team BP.
I mean they did that last time too after we won the round robin.
That's so fucked up.
That's true chat.
Jack Jesus fell on Friday.
He will rise on Sunday.
Oh true!
It is the Lord's day.
He died for our sins guys.
The two round robins probably hurt us more.
Cause this happened to us last time but...
Round one.
Fight.
Good shit.
Ooh this is...
Ooh.
He is so fast.
Coach you need to train us for this team.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Good shit.
Yes sir.
Hell yeah brother.
That's one.
Come on coach you're better.
Ooh.
We busted.
Round two.
Fight.
What am I doing?
We're having lots of fun.
Exactly.
Oh look at her life dude.
Look at the wall.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Did we send another?
Do it again.
Ouch.
Boom.
Let's go baby.
Again.
A bench match.
Oh my goodness.
You are crazy.
Dude.
Yep.
Oh my god.
All those blocks.
Boom.
One day my coach will teach me how to block.
My one weakness.
Oh wow.
What a fucking.
Let's go.
Hey teach me the Alyssa match up.
What the fuck?
Yeah we'll work on the Alyssa match up like tonight.
Uncle Baptist.
You win.
That was pretty good.
You know.
I think it's cause like Bravo didn't coach Matt.
That was the issue.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
No no no no no no.
You coached me on that.
No he didn't help him at all.
He didn't help our team.
He didn't help us at all.
I didn't get shit for Alyssa.
Exactly.
I did that myself.
You didn't help him at all bro.
You clearly knew how to counter Alyssa.
I literally didn't get any Alyssa coaching.
I'm not anything.
I went into replay.
I was like oh this is punishable.
Good to know.
And then I closed it.
He purposely did that Matt so he could look good.
And compared to you.
I'm not even kidding.
Wait what?
What is this?
Oh my god.
They swapped.
Oh.
They're not doing Alyssa anymore.
Jun Kazama.
Round one.
Fight.
Whoa.
I was not expecting this.
We were all training for Alyssa.
Okay let's not.
In case we don't press after that.
You got two scores.
He's back.
Round two.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh.
Take him to the wall.
Oh god.
Nice.
Oh.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Push her back.
This is it.
The back turn.
Yeah.
Push her back.
I love that kick.
That's funny.
That's funny that he has that.
Yeah.
Like a specific back turn.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That was her throw break.
She tried the throw break but it whiffed.
Let's get it.
I'm gonna see it soon guys.
You got so much health back.
Oh.
I saw it.
That's it.
Oh.
That was.
You stepped it?
You can.
He got nerfed but I didn't.
My punish didn't go through.
Oh.
They made it to the second.
His isn't tracking anymore.
Oh my god.
What?
Round four.
He's scared of the grab.
Fight.
Knee loops.
Nice.
Oh my goodness.
Oh my god.
It doesn't stop.
Oh it stopped.
I'm feeling justice here.
Ay.
I'm feeling justice.
I sense it in my bones.
Yup.
Ay.
Justice.
Oh my god.
Good shit.
What a confident win.
That was confident.
I think.
Dude.
That's actually a big win.
Cause it's us and them between.
For top two.
And now we're even.
Yeah.
Is that real?
Is that true?
Yeah.
Tony's number one.
Uh.
As far as I know.
Let me see.
Oh no.
I got them mixed up with uh.
MYK.
Yeah.
I was gonna say.
What about MYK?
Yeah.
That's still big.
I haven't got MYK and KFM switched up.
But still.
You just need to do well at MYK.
Then we're good to go.
Oh man.
He beat me last time.
I don't even know who's gonna lose.
Honestly I think this was sabotage for Mattman.
If this was tournament you just lost.
What does that mean?
I thought.
I thought they lost.
What's she saying?
I don't know.
No.
It was 3-2.
Dude that was a coach tiebreaker wasn't it?
Yeah.
For the.
No we would've won that.
It was a coach tiebreaker.
I don't know what they're talking about but okay.
No cause I won second round.
Yeah.
So we.
Yeah that wouldn't happen.
I don't know.
Whatever.
Yay.
Ah dude.
Woo.
Alright.
Good shit.
I don't think Alyssa players can do math.
That's what I'm saying.
One more uh.
One more round fellas.
Wait they won?
One two three two?
Oh nevermind.
Wait oh no yeah cause like slime me and Matt.
It's 2-3.
We're not.
We're not used to Matt losing.
This is sabotage.
We just assume he won.
If only Bra Pro taught Matt how to fade against Alyssa.
The only matchup that I literally don't know the matchup.
Damn the teams are pretty even.
That's.
Wow.
The king of the matchup.
The king.
Someone in my chat was like the king players don't know how to do math.
So true.
It's true.
They're hating.
I mean that's not what their specialty is.
Yeah.
We are.
We're here to crap.
I think he is 3 -teens.
Alright one more set fellas.
One more set.
Yes sir.
No.
Gonna watch myself lose them all.
I don't like it from yesterday.
Let's see what I can do.
Yeah, learn from it.
I believe in you, coach.
It's okay, guys.
This is just round robin, guys.
It doesn't matter.
The finals is when it matters.
The finals is when we're gonna fucking kill everybody.
It's not our fault everybody trained against us.
Like, that's so fucked up.
Why did everybody hard train against me?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm fucking brute forcing my way into this tournament.
Yay!
True.
Why are you training against me?
It might have been your shot.
Yeah, but it's working.
Yeah.
But like...
But like, it's not our fault.
I can't believe...
I can't believe people train against us.
That's actually so fucked up.
I don't know what I'm doing.
The fact that he trained against a King player...
It like, perfectly countered me because he knew...
He knew I only had very limited set of moves.
Wait until you master another move.
I can't believe they Vaude Reviewed.
I didn't Vaude Review...
I just learn new moves.
It's time to learn an eighth...
A seventh move.
You're right.
I just have to learn a seventh move chat.
That's all I need to do.
Oh shit.
Oh...
I just need to learn.
Oh shit!
No!
I pressed the wrong button!
That's okay!
It doesn't matter!
Because I'm... Oh okay!
Because I'm gonna grab her!
Yay!
Three kings in the leading team.
It's just messed up!
It's so messed up.
Okay, I hate playing against this girl because this girl is anti-grab.
It's actually crazy.
Like I can't do the tamaha kick with her.
See?
But I can abuse this.
Yay!
Just ally kick.
I know!
That's what I did.
Oh shit!
I didn't expect her to do that.
I didn't expect you to do that.
Oh my god!
You low kick this?
How do I get out?
She got most of her HP back!
They always fall for the ally kick because it's so stupid.
It's so fucking stupid.
I'd fall for it because of how dumb it is.
Like...
It's just so dumb.
Nobody expects it.
It works every time.
This is why I won and done because they realize I only know a specific set of moves.
Get ready for the next battle.
But because it's so low tier...
Yeah!
It's so low!
Nobody preps... nobody expects it.
That's so true.
Nobody expects...
It's so low!
It's so
low!
Alright, here we go.
Come on.
Oh my god, she has a gun!
I'm gonna fucking kill her.
She has a gun.
Oh no!
Fucking free chiropractor.
Yay!
Oh shit!
Not yay.
Not yay anymore, guys.
Not yay anymore.
Guys, it's not yay anymore.
Guys, she kicks... she... she doesn't stand up.
Yo, slide.
Does she sidestep this?
No.
What's up, is it ready?
What's up, what's up?
Dude, this is pretty stressful, man.
It's not gonna be easy to do this stuff you just learned yesterday the next day.
I wouldn't worry about it too much.
Yeah, fuck the Jhin, man.
It's just like...
Yes, definitely.
He's an annoying character, yeah.
100%.
I think that I was...
Oh my gosh, she countered that?
I was just really trying to focus on defense, which is like...
Oh my god, I went to bed.
If you're wrong when you're defending, it's really bad.
If you're wrong when you're attacking, I feel like it's way more...
Goodbye!
... at this level.
Yeah, you would duck and he would launch...
Goodbye to me, I guess.
... that forward 3, that axe kick he has.
Yeah, and he was also doing it like kind of raw.
Like I would go for a grab and he'd just rip it.
And I'm like, okay, well if like...
It just works.
... he'll block a little more.
That's not much.
Because they don't expect it.
So I don't know.
I don't know how much of it was like...
They just don't expect it.
... this guy's goaded or this guy's like...
He's alright.
I played him a little bit.
And I think he was taking some rounds off of me yesterday, was it?
I think he said that about the Feng Wei, who also destroyed me.
So I just gotta...
Those guys are...
... getting in your gear, man.
Honestly, I don't think they should even be in this tier.
The Feng, specifically.
But...
Yeah.
This is cool.
I mean, we can watch them like tonight or tomorrow if you want the matches.
Yay.
If it helps you.
I think what will help is actually playing.
Like play your Jhin or something.
Yeah.
I can definitely play Jhin to that level for sure.
I don't expect it.
I told you.
It's fine.
Yeah, that's what will help.
We can do that too.
I think that could be beneficial.
If I lose this, it's fine.
I made a statement.
She hates me.
I might have like...
If I lose this, I might have lost the game.
But like I want the mental warfare.
I got no context.
The way you said that.
I will...
It sounds like it's actually happening.
The way you said it, the tone of the voice.
I won the mental war.
It's all about exactly.
She's going to remember this forever.
Like the fucking...
Okay.
You know she's going to fucking remember this forever.
You know that.
The low kick.
Nothing dying to a low kick.
And I leave.
Exactly.
Imagine if that person has been grinding all her life to be in red rank and here I show up.
I show up and all I do is this.
Wait...
Not that.
That's sick.
How do I do that?
That's Mao Xi.
That's me.
Two touched him.
Fucking two touched him.
That's so funny.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I tried to block but it didn't work.
Jesus Christ.
Does he duck?
Okay.
He doesn't duck.
That's all that matter.
I just need to know if he ducks or not.
You're cooking this boosh in a little bit.
Oh no.
Fucking two touched in the first game.
Oh he blocks this.
There's no way he doesn't.
He's not that stupid.
He's in.
Oh the charge was crazy.
Oh my god.
He tried to sidestep that.
But he fucked it up.
And he fucked that up.
I feel bad for Fii not having his character.
Brother, a lot of these characters play differently than they used to in 7 anyways.
Yay!
And Fii is literally using fucking the evil champ character.
He'll be fine.
Nice.
He'll be alright.
Is he done now?
Nope.
He's probably best at three.
Yay!
Anything can happen.
Oh.
Nevermind.
Not yay.
Yay!
It just works.
You walked away from him.
Yeah.
I'm embarrassed.
He's a fucking weird guy.
Oh wait.
What?
That doesn't hit!
Oh.
No more yays!
Leave me alone!
I'm sorry!
No more yays.
Steve's counter hit back one of his as main.
Oh this guy would die if he backed 1 plus 2 HP.
That's 1 plus 2.
Oh shit.
If you can find an opening.
Please.
Please let me live.
Oh my god.
Please.
I blocked it.
Oh thank god.
He doesn't duck.
What?
You said not duck!
You haven't done that guard break setup today.
No I haven't.
No!
It's okay.
This is why we leave too.
Might as well go for it.
He ducked.
I can't believe it.
He actually ducked.
He doesn't duck until he does.
Alright guys.
Guys.
This time.
This time we are going to use this move.
One day we will be able to use this one.
We are going to be able to use this one.
No.
Okay.
This one.
No.
Okay.
I am going to be able to do that soon.
Game is over.
Brother the controller.
Alright.
They gave us a lobby.
Wait I am in a game.
Oh shit.
No I am being nice because he is winning now.
Okay.
He is being nice to you?
No.
They will never see it coming.
Oh is this a motion?
Oh.
It is a motion match.
Wait what rank is he?
I see through his lies.
16?
I got this one.
You want me?
Um.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He actually ducks.
Okay.
Oh it is Doki.
Maybe she is AFK.
No.
I am in a game.
I am sorry.
Don't worry.
I will lose fast.
I am going to let him have his elo.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This guy actually...
I am in a game.
Don't worry.
I am going to lose fast.
It will be done soon.
Because that guy is beating the shit out of me right now.
Oh Josh skipped Golem.
Oh yeah.
He is for this.
No no no.
He is just going to skip a lot while you are...
Oh okay okay.
Oh.
Fight.
Who is this Lucian?
Is that who Matt has to play?
Who is that Jhin player?
Oh is that a TO?
Who?
There is a Lucian Jhin player in the lobby.
They got leaked again?
No.
I think it is the TO.
Oh.
Oh that is Steve.
Oh that is tasty Steve.
Wait.
Jhin?
I thought he played King.
That is fine.
He shows you how good Jhin is.
I lost on purpose so I can get in.
I say that also.
Don't worry.
My chat knows it is right.
It is true.
It is true chat.
I lost on purpose.
Throwing for content.
This guy is lagging as shit.
We are starting.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Almost done.
No we are actually in the game.
Oh fuck.
Getting ready for the match.
We are in in.
Fuck.
I am late for my daughter's piano recital.
He doesn't care.
I am going to make it.
Now I am going to lose for real.
I lost because they weren't all there.
Keep looking to the stage.
They are careful.
Don't say.
Watch.
I threw the game because I was so sad.
Not because I am bad.
Cook our friend g lament.
Okay don't say that.
stressed.
Oh my God.
What is this.
It is you say.
When you're getting hit like that, you just... Oh, is that?
That's not opponent.
No.
When you get hit like that, just hold back.
Just hold... Wait, is that... I can't tell if it's lower mid.
They're... Those were sword slashes for mids.
Oh, okay.
Couldn't tell sometimes.
Nice.
Okay.
Good start.
Oh, she ducks!
It's like she knows!
Oh, big.
Good shit.
How does she know?
Oh, no.
I fucked...
No.
That's okay, Doki.
Now, instead of the Talog, you just run and knee her if you get distance.
Run and knee her.
Okay.
That's the X.
That's the three, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Good shit.
Okay.
That was crazy.
Good start.
Yay!
Yeah!
Oh, you're cooking it.
You're cooking this feel split.
Yeah!
I fucking knew you were going to...
I fucking knew it!
I knew it would come.
I knew you would do that!
Okay, but when do I do that?
Oh my god...
Let's go!
That hits you in the alley!
A flash bait.
Oh, battle.
Back to the ground you go!
Get the crates outta here.
Stop flying!
Who are you jumping at?
You don't have wings!
Oh no.
It does have wings.
The supreme Yoshimitsu.
That's counter hit.
You hop kick.
You hop...
It's fine.
That is so many clicks.
Oh my god.
That doggy break special.
You might have had 20 hundred coaches Gumi, but I just need one.
Oh my god.
That's a lot of kicks bro.
Damn, is that that iMusician coaching?
No.
Damn, that's a little toxic.
You guys called me broke yesterday.
Yeah, we hear the coach.
Nice.
Only two.
Yes, yes.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, what is she doing to me?
Oh, she blocked this.
Damn.
She blocked it.
If she ever jumps, she's going low.
Oh my god.
How did I miss that?
It was just a little late.
I see.
Oh fuck.
That's my bad.
I didn't know he had an instant hurry.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, fight.
That's counter hit.
Yeah.
No fucking way.
Good shit.
What a break.
Sick break.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh shit, I fucked up.
I fucked that up.
Wait, what did she do to me?
What is that?
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
Does it matter though?
Does it though?
Yeah.
One more.
Yes.
You're so fucking good.
One more.
Oh shit.
She did that thing.
Hold back.
Wait, I hold back though.
But I hold back.
How did she do that?
Nice.
Oh my goodness.
Oh.
Did I back up?
No.
I held back.
Oh good song.
Slow ass move.
My legs were up.
It wasn't fair.
Oh shit.
Rage art.
I quit.
She did that thing.
No I quit.
It's okay.
We got it.
Run your shit.
Easy.
Boom.
Oh the mix.
No.
She does that thingy.
And it scares me sometimes.
Oh what the fuck?
Did I get that?
That's clean.
That's a hit.
It hurts though when she wakes up.
I don't know though.
Does she get in time though?
It's up to you.
Commit or don't commit.
Okay we're committing.
Oh shit.
She ducked it.
So we had the running knee.
The three.
The X.
Yeah.
Ain't no big deal.
Oh my god.
She actually ducked it.
Who would have thought?
Well we adapt.
Oh.
How do we adapt?
Wait what?
Oh she do.
Nice duck.
Nice leg drop.
Shoulder shark?
Yes sir.
Don't duck.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh she did that though.
I'm scared of that.
Yay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
When she does that it's actually so hard to counter.
Sure.
Don't duck.
Yay.
Oh.
Nice hop kick.
Nice.
Okay.
Beautiful.
Oh I blocked.
I think I blocked it.
Wait what?
No you were mashing back three.
Oh yeah.
Oh it registered it.
Yeah.
Yeah my buff rate.
Oh it buffered it.
No.
I mean you have rage art too.
What?
Oh I have to stand up after that.
Okay.
Down down down back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh.
Every time she does that.
Yeah you have to mash four.
If you block it you...
The right kick.
The circle to punish that.
If you block low mash circle you will...
Yeah.
Nice hop kick.
Nice.
Oh I keep my hands is like...
It's a... yeah.
Sometimes my hands are in the wrong position.
Got that one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
Final.
You got it.
Let's go Doki.
Okay.
Oh.
I hate that attack.
Oh no I think she got me from this.
No.
That was close.
Very close.
Nice try.
It's just that spinning low thing.
That spinning one always throws me off.
Yeah.
And we will work on that.
It's very easy.
So for the tourney if we have to fight her.
We should be okay.
It's okay we got the intel now.
Oh.
Wait do I have to press four?
After I block it?
Yeah so while she is spinning.
If you just mash four that extra kick that comes out.
Won't come out and you actually hit her.
Oh.
And there is nothing.
That she can do to it.
That is like you get free damage from blocking.
Oh I see.
Oh you and Jae-Chan.
Yeah.
We are back.
Blame Ruler damn.
Gotta hit X bro.
I
got this.
Bring it back.
I just need to add more moves.
Bro let's play the game.
What the heck?
What is bro doing?
Rage art button.
Rage art button slime.
Slime.
Is he even here?
Oh shit.
King ego match.
Oh my god.
The king mirror.
This is it.
Alright let's cook.
Round one.
Fight.
Nice.
Got me ducking you.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This fighting game player.
Jae-Chan.
This guy fucking playing his fighting game.
Nice duck.
Nice yeah.
Yeah.
What a duck.
Yes.
Yes bitch.
Yeah.
Yes.
That's a one or two break.
Went after the knockdown.
Kony you have to guess.
Nice.
He engaged.
Wow.
Gamer over here.
Rush in after.
Nice.
Yeah he knows us.
Okay.
Fight.
Oh that was a good dive.
Oh my god.
Trying to duck him but.
Nice break.
If you block back one two.
Back one two and back.
He did it to you earlier.
It's a punish.
Back one.
Nice.
Nice job.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Go Kony go.
Fight.
Fuck I ducked it.
But I stood up into it.
Yeah it was a counter hit.
Oh my god that didn't grab.
Yeah it's it.
He's in full crouch during that.
Uh huh.
Ain't no thing.
And Kony you had your heal.
You died with your heal.
He also didn't use his SSL.
Right yeah.
Fuck.
Dude again I'm ducking it.
But it's like delayed.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Not even grab.
Just no.
Round two.
Fight.
Nice.
Nice kick.
Good duck.
You're in hate Kony.
Yeah I know.
Bigly.
Maybe let's not back one two as much in neutral.
But I mean do what you're comfortable.
No you're right.
Nice.
Does he not duck that?
Nope.
He's a no.
Yes.
Oh.
Nice.
I'm gonna learn more knee later.
Fight.
Oh.
Oh my god.
James.
Fuck.
Yeah.
What a fucking run.
I'm gonna break Kony.
Fuck.
Let's go King.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Cook this man.
You got this.
What a hot kick.
Yes.
Oh my god nice.
I'm supposed to be a fucking.
I'm supposed to be a fucking grab.
Yo.
Yes.
You're a fucking legend for blocking that low.
Nice.
You broke his streak.
I cannot believe you right now.
Oh my god you broke his streak.
That was so beautifully clutch.
Let's go.
I can't believe you bro.
I can feel the layers from here man.
Round one.
Holy.
This is sweat.
This is battles.
It's like rock paper scissors.
Fuck.
Okay.
I didn't know that like bounced on wall.
No problem.
There's one.
Nice.
Oh nice.
Oh.
Oh what a break.
Break nice.
You know what else?
What?
Oh.
That's what it is.
You're so clutch.
You're just better.
I can't watch this man.
This is too intense.
Yeah.
Oh good kick.
Huge.
I can't get him.
Hmm.
Oh.
He don't know.
Yeah.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
Yes bitch.
Fight.
Oh.
The missile.
Oh the missile.
Oh my god what a whiff.
Oh do it again.
Oh my god.
I love this man.
You said you're gonna buy bro pro a drink.
I'm gonna buy you a drink.
You broke his fucking win streak yo.
Let's go.
You killed his win streak and took the game.
Break his mind.
You mind broke this man.
That's the evil commentator.
He's seen it all.
You're actually him.
Just mixes bro.
Just mixes.
Woo.
Sick.
Alright.
I'm happy.
That was rough though man.
He's learned some tricks.
The disparity from two days ago.
I'm too antsy with the back one too.
I gotta really fucking stop that.
Yeah it's pretty bad.
But yeah.
He's got really bad get up habits.
I know when he's gonna stand or duck.
And it got more obvious over time.
Sure.
That was scary.
Okay.
Good shit.
Well played.
This has to be the most intense match up yet.
Here we go.
Let's go slime.
Got this.
What did you own him with last time that he probably worked on?
Wasn't he free to like back one?
I just ate a lot of back ones.
Oh you mean him.
Sorry.
He ate a lot of electrics.
Okay.
We'll try it until it doesn't work.
Cause we don't know what he's labbed.
You know how we labbed a lot.
We don't know how much he's retained either.
You know what I mean.
You can kinda play your game and we can go from there.
Yep.
Okay this guy.
What a start.
Genie club.
Oh nice day.
Alright.
That's alright.
Oh you had that.
Oh.
Good shit.
One down five more.
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
That's some good shit right there.
Good blocks dude.
Down stairs.
Nice.
Off wall killer.
Had the combo ready and everything.
Nice conversion.
Beautiful conversion.
He's learning.
Round three.
Wow that was sick.
Let her get one string.
You can feel good you know.
Okay.
Dude that's one piston.
Perfect hopkick too.
Boom.
Oh boom.
He was.
What?
Oh my god.
Eat her.
Eat her bird.
Feast mode activated.
It's hibernation time.
I'm going to sleep.
Let's fucking go slime.
One more dude.
Three more rounds you got it.
Round one.
Fight.
Yes.
Okay he's not going to learn.
Nice break.
Okay.
Oh.
Remember slime?
Stone hit to get out of the wall.
Away from the wall.
Yeah.
Oh that was nice duck.
That was so sick.
The frame trap with the movement.
Nice.
Huge.
Keep her on that wall.
Oh my god that chip.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
The infinite pressure.
She did not like that.
Oh nice flip.
They didn't fucking know man.
Round three.
Fight.
Good shit not finishing it.
That was good.
Good fucking way.
You knew.
Whipping shit like that.
You fucking knew.
Hold this bro.
You won three.
And that and this and that and the fish.
Nice.
Oh my god you broke her block.
Yeah.
Oh my god she's toxic.
Oh.
It's okay.
That's a counter hit.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
Wild Rising 1 or something.
Yeah.
It's a frame trap.
Oh there it was.
Oh.
There it is.
Big damage.
Nice.
It's a good power crushing.
It's alright.
I think after Wild Running 1 plus 2 Bear Stance.
He's not gonna duck looking for that grab.
I think you could have done another one honestly.
Okay.
Yeah I think play around the Hunting Bear Stance mix up.
And when you back one Hunting Bear Stance.
Even though that's fake as hell.
He will eat the Bear Stance 1 plus 2 every time.
Okay.
Round 1.
Fight.
Yeah that was good whiff punish.
Nice.
Got all that health back.
Why does that work?
Okay.
Probably mashing.
Yeah.
You just have to hold back.
Round 2.
Fight.
Heh.
Slap.
Good grab.
Oh she whiffed.
Stone head this man at the wall.
Why didn't that counter hit?
Whatever.
Yeah it was too late I guess.
Nice.
Round 3.
Fight.
Oh.
Look he doesn't even know it's launch.
That's great.
What a cheat card.
I didn't mean to do that.
That looks funny as fuck though.
That's so good.
That's good.
Stone head baby.
Oh.
You kicked me to the wrong side.
Good job.
Yeah.
The haunted bear stance.
That's it.
Nice.
Oh nice hit.
Oh good.
Oh again.
Let's fucking punish.
I can't believe you broke that.
That was incredible.
Nice.
That's again.
He's left there alone.
I didn't do that.
Unblockable.
You have raid.
Nice.
It's time he puts pressure on your rage.
Yeah.
When he puts pressure on your rage.
You mean like this right?
Yes.
Like this?
Like that.
Right there.
One more guess right?
You have a heat slime.
Keep up.
Got him.
Let's go.
Rip that shit.
Let's fucking go baby.
Yes.
That's our bear.
Fucking go.
That's our big baby poo bear.
I fucking.
I saw it.
And I had to fucking call it out.
Good fucking shit dude.
Woo.
We're earning it bro.
We're earning it.
Getting it back.
Man you guys are incredible.
Well done.
Oh lord.
All these matches have been so close.
And I clutched your K-monster too.
They're so fucking intense.
All our matches have been.
It's all in the mainstream too.
It's the big deal.
Dude I did that unblockable by accident.
It might have looked like almost.
That's what set up his.
That's what like.
Oh man he's gonna just.
He charged me.
I'm gonna mash.
And he got that rage up for free.
It's all set up.
This guy's on a four win streak.
It's okay.
You were on an 11 win streak.
In slams.
Technically like 18.
Across years.
Hit him on the ball Jack.
SHINee!
Yes sir.
Uh oh.
SHINee!
Nice.
I like it.
Oh.
Round two.
Fight.
Day.
One.
That was a good grab.
SHINee!
Look it's not fair.
He has a gun.
Jack has a gun.
Jack is a gun.
Jack has two.
His whole body is a gun.
Jack is his own gun.
These are all gunshots in his combos.
Why do I keep fucking getting that shit man.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my.
Yeah.
Send him to their tournament home.
Okay.
We have to walk that when we make the read on it.
We have to walk.
Oh fuck you said.
Oh man.
My expulsion.
Expulsion.
It's infamous.
Oh my god.
Nice read.
Oh.
Drop combo into kill.
USA baby.
Let's get it.
USA.
He doesn't know.
Make that grandpa retire.
He's in the corner.
There's walls on each side.
They're closing in.
Oh.
He's been in a coma for seven years.
He's dead.
Holy fucking shit man.
One.
His heart stopped midway.
What?
Oh bro's counting.
One.
Damn.
His combos are cool.
Yeah.
What a counter hit.
Oh that was good.
Oh.
Let's go.
Not too time.
Nice.
Round two.
Fight.
Take.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Blood was looking at his shoes.
He is a gun.
We don't have to wait on Sunday.
He's back now.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
Wave the white flag.
No.
Not there.
Not here.
I can't believe that explosion.
What?
Oh fuck.
That was a good break by the way.
That was bullshit damage.
Oh my god.
Oh good break though.
Round four.
Fight.
Nice.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
Oh my god.
Oh the ambulance.
It's over.
Oh my god.
That was a good game.
It's an infinite tech trap.
Jack just came back.
That's an infinite tech trap.
Okay.
You have to get up correctly otherwise you literally die.
It's a miracle.
That's crazy.
It is.
It's a miracle.
Bare time.
All right Coach.
Okay Coach.
Get him coach!
I mean, that's three wins against them right?
Yeah, but you gotta get my revenge.
He's good man.
I'm just gonna play my best whatever happens, happens.
Do your best bro.
I just do your best.
Let's go.
I'm gonna close my chat.
There it is.
Okay.
My god, he's a polar bear!
Global warming is real.
Yeah, they're on a boat now.
The shits bad.
The iceberg's melted and he's in Paris.
Show him you're the better mammal.
Good duck.
Damn.
Aw.
Back then, no problem.
Good shit.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Oh, my shiny wizard isn't coming out.
Thanks.
Okay.
Is it wall?
Let's go.
Right in their dick.
Yeah!
Lucky that shit's retracted.
Make them extinct.
Oh, no way.
It whiffed.
What the hell?
Just a whiff.
That way he stands with his legs back, I guess.
I mean, I would if I got punched in the nuts.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Throw him off the boat.
Bring him out.
No, stop that fake shit, bro.
That fake bullshit, bro.
Nice.
Well done.
Oh, yeah.
That's guaranteed.
Yeah!
That was a guess for game situation.
Oh.
It's cool.
It's fine.
It's fine, coach.
A little bit.
That was fair.
Yeah, Slime is taking notes right now.
Nice.
Might as well prolong this match so he can take more notes.
What the...
Oh.
Broke that.
He missed his health sweep.
His dusty ass health sweep.
We missed it.
Nice.
Oh, no way.
Yes for life.
Yes for your fucking life.
That's our coach.
One more.
You got this, bro.
Dusty ass health sweep.
I love you, bro.
Broke.
Let's go.
Nice.
Can't believe he didn't duck there.
You can do it.
Round one.
It's the mental games.
Show him you're the apex predator.
Oh, no way.
It crushes mid.
Nice.
The alley kick.
You love it?
Nice.
Break that off.
There it is, boys.
There's the counter play.
Nice job.
Nice.
Holy fuck.
Nice job.
Oh, my god.
That hit really nice.
Just a bad situation to be in.
You beat it.
I got nothing but a kuma cake on my screen.
Yummy.
In four.
4k.
Just big bear ass.
I know, right?
I lost the graphics.
For free?
Oh, no.
Fuck.
Nice.
It's okay.
We gave them one.
It's fine.
Let's go.
Round three.
Fight.
This fucking rock hit your scissors.
Ooh, backs up.
Okay.
We're getting back up about it.
You're not biting the fucking bait either, are you, Unk?
Yeah.
This is such a slow game of Tekken.
Oh, nice kick.
Oh.
We can settle.
That's the fuck I'm talking about.
One more, dude.
One more.
Bro, it's a turn-based game.
It is.
Nice kick.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
Mix happens.
Okay.
Fight.
Oh, nice.
Huge.
Oh, my.
Nice.
Yeah.
Let's fucking go.
I'm just using not to get in between grifstands.
One hit.
Oh.
Watch your block.
Yes.
That's crazy to me.
Such a smart fucking hit smash.
Oh, my God.
The bait.
That's gone.
Oh, my God.
That's a crazy G-Club.
You were in the air though, right?
Yeah.
I mean, it's still going to take all my great life.
Game over.
Yes.
Let's go.
That's what I'm fucking talking about.
I didn't even hear a beat.
Let's fucking go.
What the fuck are you doing?
It's so drunk.
Oh, my God.
Coach Green.
Coach, what are you doing?
Good shit.
If I do that, you'll be mad at me.
Hey.
I do as I say, not as I do.
Exactly.
Hey, I didn't want to put the pressure on you.
I think we're second seed because you won that.
Because we were one.
Yes.
Wait.
Are we second seed?
Because of that?
I didn't want to say shit.
No.
That was the tie breaker.
Really?
You got it.
You got some tie breaker, dude.
Oh, my God.
That is why we tell you after you won.
I didn't want to say it.
But it's their first seed and we're second.
Yeah.
We literally...
Just like last time, we got a seed.
We got a one.
Wait.
So we get a five?
I know.
I was silent.
You closed the chat, bro.
Close the chat.
Coney and I had like a neural link.
We just knew that it would just not be good to say.
Yeah.
Don't say that shit.
Holy fuck.
Nice.
Good fucking shit, dude.
Oh, my God.
We literally all performed.
Yay.
That was...
Good fucking shit, guys.
We turned it off.
I was so happy.
I was so happy right now.
We earned it.
We earned the fucking second seed, dude.
Oh, my God.
We did.
We came back at the end.
Yes.
That's great.
We don't have to do anything for the first match.
Let's go.
Fucking shit, guys.
We get to chill.
We get to scout.
We get to buy.
Yep.
We get to watch.
Thank God I love watching.
So proud of you guys, man.
So proud.
That was fucking sick.
Well done.
That was incredible.
Everybody came together.
It was so...
All the sets were so close too.
Fuck, man.
Y'all clutched it.
Yeah.
You clutched it, bro.
And they all trained against us.
They actually studied us.
That's true, actually.
Yeah.
They did a lot.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
They actually did their homework.
Dude, did you know last time the tiebreaker was against MYK also?
Really?
For the EVO tickets.
For EVO, yeah.
That was against the Canada.
You're just better, bro.
You're just better.
All right.
Yeah, I think we're second seed.
Nice.
Wow.
We got a lot of work to do.
We got a lot of work to do for tomorrow.
And this time...
And this time, Brocko will teach Matt.
Oh, wait.
We're third seed.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
What?
You're lying.
After four...
That's crazy.
After four-one...
Okay.
That's okay.
We'll cook them.
I'm not worried about second or third.
We play another set, but like, you know...
Don't worry about it.
Don't...
Just imagine we're second seed.
Okay.
Never let the King players do math.
Never.
Ride the high.
That's true.
He told me it was second.
My bad, yo.
I can't believe it.
You're right.
My bad, bro.
Can't listen to him.
Second in our heart.
Unless it comes down like a weird...
What?
Yeah.
What are the points looking like?
I want to look at them.
Wait, no.
Yeah.
Because we're 14-1.
We were tied with KFM.
They're crunching the numbers.
Oh, wait.
Tony...
Yeah.
They're crunching the numbers.
Okay.
We'll see.
Now SageM confirmed we're second?
I don't like this.
Wait.
Now they could be gaslighting.
Oh.
We're tied with KFM.
Wait!
Is it Tekken Ball?
Overall?
Tekken Ball.
Let me play Tekken Ball.
Wait, Seijin messed up.
Oh, wait, I read chat.
Stop.
Hold on.
I'm banning you, actually.
If it's Tekken Ball, let me play.
Wait, yeah, wait.
If we had more... if we had... if us and MYK had the same amount of points today, but we had one more point Wednesday.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, I mean it's additive, so I don't...
Oh, we're tied for second.
We're tied for second.
If it's Tekken Ball, put me on.
They're saying we're tied for second, but they didn't include yesterday, so we're second, including yesterday's points.
Apparently that's what Seijin said.
If me and MYK are tied, we should get it, because I just beat the coach.
Yeah.
The coach match just happened.
I actually get it because it was fucking stressful.
Wait, second by three points.
We're second by three points.
Let's go!
Three points?
Let's fucking go!
Doesn't that mean literally if one of us lost yesterday, then we would've Tekken Balled?
Yes.
Oh my god.
You guys clutched it out yesterday.
Or two days ago.
Oh my god, yesterday.
Yesterday was all that matters, because we got first, last one.
It literally fucking matters.
MYK's in third now.
Yay!
Wait, who do we play against then?
I was just a rollercoaster.
I was so ready to Tekken Ball it up, dude.
I got strategies that I don't even wanna talk about.
I don't wanna tell you guys just how much I grinded that shit.
Wednesday actually mattered.
Three point diff.
That's crazy.
Literally a one game difference.
That literally means everyone who won, like, Good fucking shit.
Everyone matters.
Good fucking shit.
Let's go.
This is so sick, because like, everyone on the team, like, it contributes.
Not just the team.
Oh, I can hear Josh talking.
So when is someone gonna name drop Super?
Oh.
Already a lot bigger streak than that.
Already one more case than Super.
I love the guy.
But I feel like the Doki Bird special, the Alley Kick special, that's gonna be good.
Oh yeah.
As soon as we learn to block that Yoshi, the spin of Rudy bullshit, it's easy.
Yeah, yeah.
Easy jumps.
Block that, it's over.
I can Alley Kick forever.
You think they're gonna learn how to block the Alley Kick, guys?
We were only two points away from first also.
Oh shit.
Yeah, if we won one more set against them.
But I mean, first or second doesn't...
It doesn't matter, right?
We're just on the other side of the bracket, from my understanding.
Does it matter?
We're first or second?
If I'm like, hey, our third seed, then we just 4-1'd them.
So like, you know, we're not in a bad spot.
I'm gonna ask Stage 1, see if anyone wants to play Tekken this month.
And also, we don't have... once the bracket comes out, we don't have to focus on like five characters.
Cause we gotta buy.
Yeah.
Maybe we might?
With the loser bracket?
I don't know actually how that works.
We'll start to prepare, yeah, for whatever comes up.
Yeah.
I think it's mathematically we'll be less characters to focus on.
The moment you teach me how to block, I'm unstoppable.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, we'll do all that.
Like it'll be a read, but by definition, we have to lab against like at least one less team.
Oh, good shit guys.
Well done today.
Seriously.
Hell yeah.
Wow.
Crazy.
This is really like rough on the mental, I'm not gonna lie.
This one ironically hurts.
And the thing is like, I don't know.
It's just pride.
Cause like we're already going.
You don't need to leave here alone bro.
Excuse me, I'm here too.
You just don't wanna let your friends down.
It's so hard.
I don't wanna let you guys down, you know?
I mean, but like at the same time.
Doesn't matter.
Yeah, we're already going.
Wait, excuse me.
Hello?
Guys, hello?
The chat is paying for it.
Hello?
We can create a fucking like a little thing, a group thing.
We'll just all pick.
Cause you're part of the team too.
True.
Yeah, let's do it for Doki though.
That's the first option.
Then we'll do a donation drive for a millionaire after.
First option is we try and get top two.
I'm not gonna use my own money.
Lost my two points for one by two points.
I would have loved to beat Josh's team so bad.
If you beat Josh bro, we would have been first seed.
I lost to his coach too.
No, it is just his fault.
It's okay, I choked too guys.
It's okay.
We all, each of us choked at least once guys.
It's a team effort.
That's a second though as a team effort.
Yeah, yeah.
My chat is saying give her supers ticket.
That's what my chat is saying too.
That's what I'm saying dude.
Drop it over.
Make super pay for his own ticket.
I gave away my first ticket cause I already had an evil fucking...
Like I already had a ticket.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah, I was like here SageM, just give it to someone else.
SageM saves money if we win.
Yeah.
So it's in his interest to rig the bracket.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Look at how close we were dude.
Oh my god, we were so close.
That's crazy man.
If by knock on wood, not gonna happen.
But if we don't get top two, we'll all pitch in and get Doki Da Ivo too.
Yeah.
Because I mean, clutch master Doki, literally every match mattered.
Doki clutched that shit.
Yeah.
Wait, did my set count?
Every win counted.
Every win.
I got sets.
There's no way I don't...
You deserve to be an Ivo.
I got points from SK.
Yeah, you literally farmed.
Yeah.
Well, every snap mattered.
I don't think every match, right?
How did it work?
Every match turns into every set.
And every set matters.
So you got points off the guys you beat?
Yeah.
Wait, off the points I got sets off?
So how many people did you beat in a set?
It was like a couple, right?
I beat Amore, but then I got set off SK and Gumi.
You went like, what?
2-3, 3-2, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm like, I'm a difference maker.
Like, it's crazy.
Woo!
That King Heat match when he's growling.
Yay!
That's a good clip.
That was a really...
It was like right as he looked into the camera.
It was very funny.
Did you see it?
Did you see the clip?
Chat, send me the clip, please.
It's extremely fucking funny.
My POV...
Yeah, hold on, here you go.
I'm gonna post it in the thing.
It is extremely good.
Hold on.
Here you go.
Watch this.
Put this on stream.
Yay!
Title!
Alright.
I'm gonna go get food.
Congratulations, everyone.
Holy fucking...
Where'd it go?
Are you just reading?
Yeah, I mean like...
Uncle, are you staying live?
Me?
I mean, what am I gonna do?
I guess I'll stay live for like 30 minutes or something.
Sure.
Alright.
We'll give BrawlPro...
I'll send BrawlPro the rate, bro.
You sound so enthusiastic.
Coach!
Hold on, let me get my 90 second ad ready.
Hold on.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Get the ad revenue.
I'm ready.
Alright, good shit, bro.
Alright, guys.
See you in two days.
GG's, guys.
We'll train, bro.
Let's get it.
We're gonna train for real.
You can see me in purple rank.
GG's.
Oh my god!
Guys!
We got second!
SK and Gumi!
It's an improvement!
I gotta say almost everybody!
Oh my god, BrawlPro is fucking jamming it out right now.
Guys, SK in the finals.
We're definitely gonna have our new PC.
And the shackles will be off for real.
And we got RedRank on stream too!
Guys!
We got RedRank on stream!
To be fair, I feel like I've been...
I honestly feel like I brute-forced RedRank.
Because all I did was just do the moves I know and then leave.
I just...
I just do like the most tilting fucking moves that nobody has ever seen before.
I call it the Doki Special.
With five alley kicks and then into a hop kick.
Red...
Red is red.
These people in those ranks did not know what they saw.
I'm pretty sure I tilted a lot of people.
I was so surprised that the match against SK was so close because she had so many hours ahead of me.
I hard grinded the last this week.
But SK still had so many hours ahead of me.
Everybody had so many hours ahead of me.
Throughout this tournament.
So I felt like I definitely grew a lot in such a short amount of time.
And I did!
I don't like... I don't defend.
I just go in YOLO.
The mind game.
I feel like I caught up really fast in the short amount of hours.
I think I have like 30 hours in total at the moment in Tekken for now.
But I'm pretty like...
And it's my first fighting game.
So I'm really happy with my progress so far.
Like I never expected to get red rank at all.
So I'm super happy with my progress!
And I honestly think the moment I learned how to block it's fucking over for everybody.
That's my only problem!
The moment I learned to block and I become more patient it's over.
I figured it out.
Because I win the mental game.
Like I win the mind games off of people.
Because when they fight against me it's so... I can feel the rage.
I can feel people being really angry when they're fighting against me.
Because my moves are so fucking bullshit.
Like...
My moves are so...
bullshit.
And I can tell people are very mad.
You see them getting more aggressive?
Oh hell yeah.
I can feel that they're deafening and like going hard focused.
I can feel it.
I just need to learn how to block and it's over.
Block, alley kick, alley kick, jump kick, bam.
Done.
They better learn.
Hey guys!
I hope you guys enjoyed today's event.
We got second place overall!
It was so close too.
We're second place overall.
I'm really proud of my team.
And I'm happy that my sets actually contributed to...
Because I thought since I only won one game that was it.
I only contributed one game.
But I'm happy that my sets actually mattered.
And it actually contributed into the score overall.
So I'm glad that I'm happy that it actually helped the team with the score.
So yay!
Because I didn't lose both sets.
I won one out of a set.
Which is why I'm happy.
Hey guys!
I'm gonna call it a day.
I'm gonna relax a little bit.
Get some behind the scenes work done.
And then I'll start training again tomorrow.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Any of you?
Stay up for me?
Head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!